getting the host by the Destiny show
nice shout-out to the Destiny show thank
you guys
salute all right so we're gonna cross
our fingers guys if you are in here hang
with us if it drops trying to refresh if
it hangs real bad audio and video will
be up later I don't want to resort to
that but at some point I don't want to
kill this man sleep forever so we're
gonna have to do something yeah it's
gotta go at some point can I hear you or
users ultra-quiet me I'm acting like a
phantom I'll shut up shut the Destiny
show guys if you don't follow him follow
the Destiny show over there they put on
a great lot cast as well following on
Twitter follow them a twitch shout them
out ninja and the cheetah have
surrounded the campfire today though so
it is a two-man show today so we gonna
get it going so I'll give you that three
and then it's all on you don't hit your
mic sorry yeah definitely don't tap on
your desk yeah that too
no drummond so alright alright at three
all you and just three alright and we
are live again the last word with lord
Cognito
in a bat boxes hot body campfire not
much to discuss I don't think so it's a
quiet week it's weird like haven't seen
a lot in the news that didn't have much
reading material yesterday at all
it's really weird so really no guys we
are absolutely just messing with you
guys I've never seen a table with bullet
points we got a launch trailer we are
four days away and three sleeps away
from the launch of just absolute
insanity
we got clarification on new light which
is even more than I expected it to be I
mean we are we are going crazy with
information here so we got a lot to talk
about so strap in we're going to talk
about a little bit about the trailer but
honestly like we've seen as many of the
videos as we can get I want to talk
about the new light image slate kind of
as much as we can really so when we get
to that new light image we've got a lot
of things to think about here not just
with what's being given to given to new
people for free how their accessibility
is gonna go they're still
questions about that and then we have
one of the biggest longest Wobs to talk
about with changes like every bullet
point so I'm sorry we have bullet points
about the sections in every section as
bullet points and those bullet points
will need to get talked about so it is
ridiculous this morning but before we
get going too far I want to thank all of
you guys for tuning in this morning if
you were catching us on Twitch you guys
are live you are awesome you always make
it fun to have this podcast so if you
don't catch us live follow this twitch
channel twitch.tv slash abundance is
also follow iron Lords podcast on
YouTube and Twitter as well so you guys
know when we go live we've got content
up there my channels his channels we're
all over the place but before we get too
far I do want to let you guys know if
you aren't on audio finding me on
Twitter but this is Ibanez talking I've
got a giveaway going on so to celebrate
shadow keep for new light players for
new content creators for people have
been in the business for a little while
I got to give away going for a stream
deck now some people may wonder what the
elgato stream deck is some people may
not even know what the heck it does but
it's honestly one of the most easily
useful tools that I've had for my stream
for I use it to set this thing up I turn
my light on and off I set up the
recordings I know there's big tech
channels that the video editors use his
stream deck is like a combination all
these hotkeys and stuff their uses it's
basically a custom board of buttons that
you can make do whatever you want to so
it's a really really cool thing so if
you want to get in on that there's some
ways to enter head over to my Twitter
you'll see it up at the-- it's pinned at
the top so twitter.com slash montes
you'll find it sure if you don't have
one check it out it's a really really
cool too and I was lucky enough to get
to give one away to the community so
it's kind of a nice way to support and
celebrate shadow keep so I thought that
was actually fun yeah make sure you guys
go and support emag tremendous man in
the community doing giveaways you got to
support I'll put that thing up man so
yeah check out his Twitter get in there
make yourself stream deck man win
something free 99 it is free 19 I'll
give you that is free 99 and apparently
I was like I was checking like shipping
locations and it goes basically
everywhere so worldwide except
Antarctica or ridiculous places so most
normal places we can ship to figure out
a shipping address we'll probably get it
there
so yeah what do you been up to I've been
I've been working on preparation content
like everybody's like oh I'm grinding up
my final weapons like I'm grinding out
videos for it next to the exact other
thing that it's good to see it's kind of
the same repeat performance for me from
last week it's been um just grinding
things that just want to items I call my
vanity items that I just want so that
I'm ready for shadow chief or whatever
the meta and boy we I have a whole bunch
of metas going oh man it's gonna be a
different animal yeah I'm just getting
ready man so basically the last thing
was a Izanami 'he's burdens catalyst so
uh did you get it oh yes Shou I got a
shoutout the castle community you no
disrespect of a PC brethren but shoutout
to Xbox Live lfg I'm telling you right
now II it is by far the best energy I
have ever been in like literally like I
just put in search I got it into a match
of six people wanting to do that
menagerie in five minutes unless I got
it done so it is what it is just so many
people it's integrated its baked into
the UI of Xbox Live it's really good man
I just hope like somehow like PC can
mirror that it's kind of hard because
pcs kind of segmented but at the same
time like I have to still shout them out
man I got that bad boy now so that's
what cross save helped me get things
done putting that cross save to use
before shadow keyboardist yeah
absolutely so that's that's pretty much
it so I got amazing I've been run around
to 500 kills and everything yeah I think
I was gonna try for spire on sleeper
catalyst but I'm just like you know our
anger time and that no one's running
that rate that that rape Leviathan no
one's running amory I'll give it about a
week and you'll have some people wanted
to put up for other reasons we shall
talk about yes yeah so it's been kind of
similar for me I ground out I've got a
video together that I'm gonna put out
there for all heroic how to do every
public event in heroic style for the
world
berries that are come into the community
yes and I don't know if you saw that
tweet somebody made like they have
titles out there for like dredgen and
reckoner and curse breaker somebody got
fancy in photoshop and made a blueberry
title and I about fell down hilarious
man there was one that was like all
right have at least five motes do not
Bank them invade and then get killed
within five seconds tango sure as soon
as the prison about I mean it was guy
comes out kill him and don't freeze him
yeah absolutely
tries to be bits oh yeah no public
events first that was the funny thing is
is like define irony I'm making a public
event video showing how to make heroic
events public for all the new people are
they're going to be coming to the
community the first to I tried to make I
failed because people killed it too fast
yep I was like it's still going on bro
I'm like homo guys yeah so public events
yeah I learn how to make him heroic you
don't know how I'll have a video up in a
little while
except there's probably gonna be a moon
public event so I probably want to get
that one on there but yeah it's a dying
if you if you invade and die in five
seconds you know what that happens
because that happens to me too some
people are just like on the money then
they like know the spawn locations but
if you made with moats yeah yeah you
messed up you messed up yeah so yeah
that was that was a nice little
entertaining piece to the to to the day
and then we're all sitting there like
breaking our f5 key on our keyboard and
I think we owe as many times does
everybody hate it I think that's how
many words are in this table this is
serious man we got serious business to
discuss
so I kind of want to go in a little bit
of like so for the launch trailer I
won't ask you anything you spotted from
that because I know I broke down a
couple frames I didn't do a video over
it but I did actually stream and kind of
break down frames of it what did you
catch from the launch trailer anything
piqued your fancy anything catch your
interest yes the beat yeah it was like
it was awesome marketing video like
rocket baby I was always great Bungie
know how to advertise man that's one
thing I was worried about
with them leaving activation just to see
it's all on them and man they got the
party started
you got oh my homegirl you know saying
talk as I talk so it's always good to
hear more like you know she gets into
that Rilke tonic state is just is dope
you don't say I mean as far as what I
saw I mean to me was just more more of a
little bit of everything else but I mean
that we kind of seen already but um it's
just we just put together well man i I'm
ready I'm ready I can't think of any
what standouts for you specifically I'm
trying to think of anything that really
specifically stood out there are a
couple like of the new hive theme on the
moon like with the red and the spikes
and stuff we saw the sparrow at the end
is actually the hive Sparrow which you
know that's gonna be collectibles crazy
quest dungeon it's gonna be some like I
don't think that's gonna be a random
drop I think that's gonna be earned we
saw would look to be a similar theme
with the high of the red the tan and the
spikes a shotgun so we actually got a
teaser themed weapons and a little
little more info about that in the swab
later on so those were actually cool
because we have some some of those
themed weapons because we've seen like
we've seen the leafy weapons like coming
from black garden or vex we've seen the
Astra shaman weapons and I've seen a few
exotics but it was like we have this
whole like hive theme and they nailed it
like all those weapons that the one that
I've seen looks like anything with that
theme is gonna come back to like taking
king style weapons like matching the
name of the place like it's gonna be
really really good so yeah I think that
just got me excited of more themed
weapons being more variety of stuff to
get out there so yeah absolutely
I'm sure I also like the little Petach
of them in the vehicles again shooting
off have to keep and stuff like that
yeah it's kind of cool yeah that was
like yeah that was kind of cool yeah
that was a that was a cinematic put
together I'm sure that's not gonna be
yeah a full like like a six-person
anywhere but there were some people
messing around having fun in there
absolutely looks good it looks good
ready man got the juices are blowing man
definitely I love the trailer man got me
night yeah so short and sweet on the
trailer if you want to watch it check it
out we broke it down some frames
looked at some pieces but really it's
just four days around the corner so the
more I look at the more I want it so I'm
just gonna stop breaking everything down
yeah and then we had Twitter explode
with a graphic about new light yes
now I've been wondering for the longest
time well it's gonna be a new light what
are free players gonna get because they
get to log in at 7:50 we knew that we
knew they're gonna play like planets
were kind of gonna unlock overtime they
were probably gonna get some of the
basic strikes we got like the full
infographic everything's there yeah oh
what'd they get access to if you are if
you don't haven't bought anything
haven't played dusty - maybe you just
want to jump in on Steam you can play
all of this stuff without paying a cent
wherever you play it yes so even if you
go to like cross save or something
you're like hey I want to go run so I
want to go run fill in the blank you'll
still be able to do all this stuff
mm-hmm so we've got crucible of course
access to all playlists free seasonal
updates crucible weapons and gear so all
that stuff will be there crucible that's
gonna be nice I think just in every I'm
just as your cross playing on xbox
sometimes PlayStation already has a lot
of people but hopefully should be
getting some more and then steam getting
a lot of free people I'm sure he's gonna
be really explosive I mean steam is by
Father you know number one oh and by the
way how about that subtle uh-oh you can
preload steam already brah I don't let
that thing yo it was like 80 gigs for
79.1
yeah yeah I'll put that bad boy on an
SSD I'm ready laughing we'll see ya
speaking of my internet connection so I
get our if the streams terrible but like
I was download my internet connection I
doubt that thing at 450 mega second yeah
it worked
that baby flexor that's that's hot my
brother makes me look bet he's got gig
up and down he's down there in Austin
knows he's got some pretty fancy
internet yeah so my bro yeah I was down
there once and uploaded a video doing
weekly reset video takes a little while
to upload 60 frames you know take some
time it was done in 30 seconds literally
the whole video was uploaded I was like
it was just like the bar goes
so yeah that was so good I mean I'm so
glad they did that because again the
influx of what's about to happen next
week is going to be insane people don't
understand like this is unlike any other
destiny launch this is literally great
content combined with cross save
combined with new light I have so many
people hitting me up saying yo I want to
play with you these are non destiny
people I'm just letting you know so it's
gonna all platforms man get ready you're
ready man it's gonna be a big one yeah
so that alone like I think that's gonna
help on all platforms I mean crucibles
one of those were people of like wait
times on PC for comp or other things in
this nature and it's like the playlist I
think we'll be better off on all fronts
oh we're gonna have more playlist so it
is gonna be hopefully a good thing that
holds on for a while yeah then we've got
strikes
so the PvE side of things you've got the
strike playlist direct launch of year
one strikes and then Vanguard weapons
and gear so again they do clarify year
one strikes and they also clear clarify
later on it's year one nightfall strikes
are gonna be an option so they can't do
some night falls I'm good nightfall is
gonna be changing up it's gonna be
nightfall the ordeal all four
difficulties and stuff like that I mean
from all we've seen and they're gonna
still be able to you know stretch their
legs and try some challenging content
for sure mm-hmm absolutely was going on
for five years gonna be live bender in
the house was going on him seriously
yeah it's like we got we got a good
check on this morning guys thank you
guys for tuning in live no we've got
year one exotic weapons and armor
mmm-hmm so on year one exotic weapons
and armor you go through and that still
pretty good chunk I mean four seconds
got a large like list of exotics that
are in there but that's still a pretty
good amount of stuff for them to work on
collecting I mean if you've never played
before that's still a big list and we
know about four or five of those exotics
from year one are about to be looking
really good looking really sweet yeah
yeah crazy buff so yeah I mean listen
that's a ton of exotics don't you know
obviously everyone wants to not new
shiny stuff but to a new player he's
ignorant to that stuff he doesn't know
you know what dis new whatever is he's
just getting you know all these other
exotics for the first time is gonna be
losing his son his son shot graviton
lands with you enhanced you know people
gonna get sweet business for all time is
so good yeah I love Alan G oh man but
just a dude like double tap against the
way a sound it sounds like a like a
lightsaber just it's a cool sounding gun
I always like described it they're like
the first bullet basically clears the
air out of the way for the second bullet
to hit and I was like are you kidding me
you're gonna make me actually think
about the physics of that and then it
sounds like nailed it so no graviton
Malone but yeah they got a lot of stuff
coming is that on real quick is that my
favorite fan tree is that all Malone
leave this I'm a lot got it I don't know
says it but it I feel like it's gotta be
I feel like that's like on the lawn
exotic in the in the wind there's that
stuff yeah tech science love that stuff
so you got access to three campaigns you
got a red war curse of Osiris and war
mind now for free that's legit that's
like I mean warframe has like multiple
campaigns and stuff out that they go
through
I know people didn't love curse of
Osiris it was kind of short no Cyrus did
not get the love you supposed to war
mind was kind of cool teasing at it but
let's see the red war campaign I know it
wasn't like the best but I thought it
was like up until forsaken because that
obviously set the bar higher I really
liked like you got to see more of Gaul
you got to see more of the Vil and you
kind of got to see the progression of
him talking to the speaker like oh yeah
I really enjoy the red war campaign
because I think that first that first
mission and then going into to it's like
hello music and stuff the tone and some
of those missions was great so that's
going to be some awesome stuff yeah
absolutely that was we still honeymoon
phase we've just so great because it was
such a narrative attention to detail you
know we had the good cinematic
old-school Bungie quality Gaul was an
interesting feeling you know yeah crazy
interactions man mm-hmm
yeah so three campaigns and then as they
go through the campaign's they'll be
unlocking destinations but they get free
roam access to everywhere and the
Dreaming city tangled Shore on top of
all the other campaigns they're gonna
play they get to see it all so if like
you know this play
is really cool and there's you're
telling me there's more stuff here I
guess I gotta dig into this and there
were a couple things I was actually
thinking about when it came to
destinations I was like so how are
people gonna get their charts of light
or seeds of light
rye I showed I was a good question you
put up a so yeah so I wondered and then
people are like well the patrols should
still be open so you still should be
able to get to blind well and then you
should still be able to go to Marsala
and do Tier three so I think I think
they've covered just about there were
some questions I had and then even more
questions I had because up until
yesterday I did not know the following
was going to be part of Menagerie sorry
part of do light you got the forges you
got gambit Prime and reckoning or both
confirmed to be in there and the minute
so the entire annual pass is free wow
that is huge but yeah I didn't think it
would go that far like that's a big deal
that is a lot of freaking like you
literally don't have to spend no money
and you could be playing with your
friends and still going everywhere and
then what I like what you said about
lying well let's be real like sometimes
when you need to go on blind whether it
be a little rough trying to get people
to get you guys they just off of the
queueing yeah weird
I like what bungees doing maybe using to
do like to feed their ills activities
that gap you think that might be a
little oh you're gonna have blueberries
in there so it may be rough as you're
teaching people but yeah you'll have
people you'll have bodies I just don't
know if they're gonna be helpful bodies
really well so it's a dramatic you
automatically my best friend now he like
even like that's my man yo salute okay
so I really uh I dug Panoptix
as that final boss I guess we got to see
something more with him but not this was
legit looking at like oh my god
screenshots of him that are just like I
was like he's an epic design so cool
design and the boss fight was cool
because you shout the agony without
excited is that it's one of the first
boss fights where the Guardian is like
fighting with Osiris it's free yeah he's
right alongside you kind of do this do
that like don't get me wrong I'll use
the man and stuff like that just that
again the resolution we didn't
necessarily care for also my personal
gripe was just that most like like when
you do warm up
and a Bray stays as an NPC right yeah I
thought we would at least have him
somewhere just known yeah you know ask
you there so um yeah like it's just one
of those things where just liked him you
know it just do that you're talking
about Anna Bay in there you know yeah a
lot of people a lot of people like Anna
Bay and I was like whoa okay calm down a
lot she is highly contested so my
apologies to Anna Bay but um yeah man
like again you know just one of those
things that you hope they revisit and
now that they're doing with a annual
season past 2.0 narrative we hope once
we get a chance maybe and you know here
for whoever what we get to see them
again hopefully yeah that's been some of
the biggest things like the big
expansions like we know shadow keeps
gonna have a cool campaign it's gonna
tie in so whatever's going on with the
VEX and it's gonna go forward and that's
like that's what we've been all waiting
for for a while like red horse campaign
is cool and we have like Nittis with the
menagerie connection which is like one
of the first times they even can I get
for that so I'm looking forward to more
and more things coming together they
also get gambit regular game but along
with gambit prime private matches if
they want to do that yeah I'm big how do
you think they would get daddy
that's privates really yeah I mean I
don't even know how many people use them
they're just in there but it's their
raids they all three year one raids and
the weapons and gear so you can get you
know you can go get your inaugural
address and things like that it is weird
that some of the raids that they're
doing there don't have random rolls on
them so you're just getting the stacking
pieces yeah is it confirmed that year
one you know raid weapons won't be
upgraded to cuz we know it because they
can't even Bob's in those canyons
you can't put a mod in and what like an
all-girl address or midnight coup like
you can't put a lot in any of those can
you but it's so weird right because
there up the armor in the raids they're
making armor - Wow yeah armor 2.0 I hope
so I hope so man I only just silently
pushed him out and allow could you a
matte like I would love to grab up
midnight coup and an augur like grass
they have like the best perks you can
ask for on them though so it's really
our does my joint - um just shoddy
zenith of your zenith of our kind yeah
yeah that was a me
shoddy man so you'll see uh I will hope
so I mean we never heard any indication
but you know we also which version of
the game are we picking up well I'm
gonna get the one that has all the
seasons cuz as well I'm gonna play it so
I'm gonna get the deluxe I didn't do the
collectors I didn't actually jump on it
on time I went to go look at one point I
was like they were sold out is like no
yeah yeah I'm doing the digital deluxe
on Steam deluxe all the trimmings extra
extra sauce all the fixings if you're
gonna go a little suffering with it yeah
we know we know he loves his vixens no I
really don't actually and I still get to
do in-game events he got iron banner
festival loss the dawning crimson days
the revelry solstice of Heroes I guess
they're telling us their play those are
the play and events of the year so the
season limits are still gonna be there
you get this you get that much for free
I mean this is look easier for them to
describe what you don't get then what
you do get you literally don't get the
Forsaken campaign last wish shattered
throne and like the quests that go with
Basel for seconds here but the fact that
you could you can go to the areas like
the Dreaming city you know I'm saying
and all that stuff that's pretty cool no
that's pretty cool so at least it gives
some the temptation so you know this
looks cool I'll put that money down you
know saying I'll put that money now for
this forsaken or whatever show there was
one thing I was going through and I was
like working on a preparation video and
like what to do and I was like because I
was thinking about machine guns I know
they're probably not gonna be as crazy
and gambit hopefully the range fall-off
doesn't make hammerhead quite a beast I
mean if you're mid range you're still
probably gonna whoop somebody but yeah
you're not gonna cross map and but I was
like weird because I was thinking about
what a new light Guardians gonna have
for machine guns and I was going they're
gonna just have a chance at thunderlord
before I knew this it was just under
Lord that was all I could think and then
you've got like armory and you've got
vinegary and you've got the raids like
so
I guess they won't be doing the raids
they won't be doing scourge they won't
be doing crown those they have to go
so that would come with forsaken I think
so yeah silly like man if you're one of
those like a same thing if you buy a
console late in a generation like if you
got a ps4 right now you would have so
much stuff to play it would be just
ridiculous like and you could get it
fairly cheap enjoy so many games you'd
be like just gaming for the next couple
years so same thing if you manage to not
play destiny to for a while you are
gonna get a nice place to jump into it
let's go blueberries come forth yeah
blueberries come forth and ruin my
public public events and bring them into
the crucible for my KP chand Pro I see I
see yeah you want some you want some
like lost heads be like oh what's this
corner do I beat you feel good about
myself
oh man so yeah that's everything coming
we'll get to that in a bit black wings
here what a couple steps ahead of us
they're ready you ready yeah new light
is honestly looking to be really really
amazing for this game I think it's
something even when we sit there and you
know you ask some of the devs and stuff
like what are things they're looking
forward to you know this has to be high
on their list this is something that I
think they've probably wanted to do in
some way but weren't able to and just
the way to cuz everything's always been
buy this buy that buy these pieces buy
this here like there's no way even like
the D the annual pass content would have
been free with new light otherwise so I
agree this is definitely their long-term
original vision I don't like I can't
wait looking forward to it for sure
so there should be love you so we've got
probably one of the biggest Wobs I've
ever seen mmm I mean I say that we had a
lot of patch notes but this is like
everything has something to talk about
so they give us the bullet points combat
changes progression and economy changes
patched no preview ritual and weapon /
that's a big one set it straight wear it
with pride and Bungie rewards like we'll
get to some of those but like those top
like four holy crap we got we got some
stuff to talk about guys so we are
we're gonna break down this stuff kind
of get our talking points about each
I'll set them up cockney gold knock him
out and we will work through this thing
with you guys and again sorry on the
stream if it is bad check the video
later I do apologize it's one of those
things yeah I have no control over this
morning so good brother we rockin out
all right so we're gonna go to combat
changes first some of this is like UI
stuff someone's gonna be the levels that
you fight so basically they've stated
the whole PDE number just display to
wrap this up into a kind of a tight
little bow it doesn't reflect anything
that we're doing yet doesn't affect the
level the two are doesn't affect your
damage output it literally changes the
numbers on screen so they're not seeing
like nine nine nine nine nine nine
showing up when you're golden guide
they're gonna bring the numbers down and
as they have five years of growth
projected for us we're gonna be able to
basically look forward to actually
enjoying that growth and not have to
change the numbers because they even
state as players grow in power damage
numbers will increase at a much more
measured pace than previously and this
is you know built to last for years
they're just they're setting us up for
you know when you shoot an ogre in the
face it's not gonna do twenty 1260
damage it's probably gonna do twenty one
hundred damage they're just like they're
gonna take the zeros off of things you
may not see the rounding that's out
there but all in all just gonna make
things a little more manageable all UI
visual front-facing stuff not affecting
damaged stuff this is literally just
future proofreading for the UI yes my
god yeah I mean honestly what you can
picture is PvP because most of the time
we're looking at PvP we're seeing like
I'll hit him for like 61 and with same
gun you go into PvE and you hit they for
all in the head for 6000 damage you're
like mmhmm yeah so it's just basically
UI thing nothing's gonna change player
damage output whether measured as hits
to kill time to kill or DPS remains
unchanged by this update so don't need
to spend much time on that one just
numbers are gonna look different don't
worry about it the best way I can say
that now PvE difficulty tuning that's a
legit thing so goals they want to widen
the sweet spot where fighting higher
level combatants provides a fun
challenging rewarding combat experience
for a more enjoyable power climb also
allow players to look for even greater
challenges to confront much higher level
enemies all I can say is esoteric slick
whoo I can fight something 99 powers
above my power level and still do
something to him so I'm only waiting for
him on like day one to solo at nightfall
unlike legends he's gonna like solar
night it's gonna be crazy so so we've
got combatants that are 10 to 40 levels
to higher take a little let take less
time to kill and deal less damage we
don't have a lot of moments where things
are above us mm-hmm but when they are
say like raid contests and things like
that we're we're kind of stuck below
this stuff won't be as bad which this
also makes me wonder is like kind of the
raid contest is it gonna be not as bad
no that's what I'm wondering I wonder in
that yeah when you do hear their stuff
you know in reference to the to the raid
how will that affect it I mean yeah 10
to 40 levels higher take less time to
kill it we go see a lot of this stuff
remember we're seeing it this were
information and then we also the week
prior we're getting like little bit of
damage buffs per weapon and something we
got to see how things even now with all
these systems coming together before I
completely say oh this is terrible or
you know I'm saying hey or whatever you
know I mean this may sound weird y'all
okay maybe contest isn't that strong or
things above me are like maybe not
hitting me that hard but I also like
where it leads into this next part which
they'll get a bigger range of stuff that
we can fight so higher-level combatants
continue to increase in difficulty up to
100 power levels above the player and
above you know 100 power levels are
above they are immune so you can do
basically up to a hundred or basically
99 it's the way I read it you can do
damage so if you are what is the new max
like a legend difficulty nightmare hunt
is 950 if you are 51 technically you
could do damage in there just may take
you like three hours to finish it gonna
be rough but but it is definitely I like
that though because you can venture into
places and be like maybe I shouldn't be
here we don't really have
those right now and I and I'm also
wondering how like you take this and I
can picture the moon I'm like hey maybe
there's some areas of moon where there's
some difficult enemies and then
Nightmare hunts and night falls and
stuff like that I'm honestly wondering
or hoping if they're gonna throw
higher-level enemies in other patrol
places around that's what I'm thinking
that's the vibe I'm getting
that's literally about it it almost
reminds me of on cosmic drone and you
get into some areas where you like whoa
you know question mark old-school
question mark but you don't say like you
know what's going on here like I
shouldn't be here because of the level
of the enemy so yeah I think they're
setting things up with that also we have
like you said the nightmare ons there's
something scheming there's this this is
the vibe of get where anybody with a
name plate on your name you got a name
plate also them dudes yeah it's gonna be
serious so I think this'll open up them
to be able to be a little more creative
what's a lost sectors are more difficult
thing like run around on patrol law
sectors they might be a bit more
challenge like I'm hoping they start
getting creative with stuff like that
so we actually have places where we
potentially when you're leveling up or
when you trip over a new zone you're
like oh oh this is too high like maybe
you shouldn't go March to keep on the
first day because you're gonna get
stepped on yeah absolutely
hopefully at least we'll see but yeah a
couple couple difficulties but yeah but
UI is not gonna mean much but the pde
difficulty mostly just giving us cuz oh
it was up to 50 at this point 50 is
where they'd be immune you're getting 49
points and that's why if you messed with
the nightfall card though that was kind
of where you'd have to cap it out it's
like one underneath that mmm speaking of
that nightfall card by the way yes do
you think that thing's just gonna
disappear
I hope so cuz I'll be honest II I
develop never liked it it felt like
homework alright pull out your home pull
out your scratch card and let's why
can't it just be easily baked into the
UI they got a little too cute and it's
just it feels like work it feels like
busywork just to set up but that's what
WI was you that's why I don't do
like usually when I doing that is
because someone says hey I need help
alright cool I got you just tell me what
you want what you what loadout you want
which one what burn you want me to take
care of and I'll help out but um I I'm
hoping man I'm not really a fan of only
thing I will say I like is I liked the
creativity with the banners how they can
change your score or yeah that but the
emblems you mean the emblems yeah yeah
the emblems I like that you know there's
some cool variants you know I'm saying
and that's a little show-off kind of
stuff but um yeah little flecks
yeah mix I mean I think that card cuz I
kept like going through my inventory of
things to prep what to keep whatnot and
I'm looking at that challenge card I'm
like there's like four difficulties this
thing iswhat I thinks just gone I have a
feeling you had to get it from zur you
don't even know what's going on with
that it's too complex for a dimply too
convoluted mm-hmm so I think that's
actually straight-up gone you're gonna
have your four difficulties they're
gonna pick the modifiers the stacks the
things you're gonna face and it's
basically up to them
yeah which will be also kind of a thing
where it's like hey so what loadout or
what's in should I pick look it they
picked it just good luck just good luck
yeah so that's one of those I'll be
curious if they keep it to where because
you've got new light players who could
do year one night falls and then we're
gonna have year two strikes you've still
got like corrupted and stuff like that
and then now we're gonna have a couple
more additions and then we had the
Forsaken the Forsaken playstation strike
that we're gonna get so there's a chunk
two strikes the people they won't have
access to so I'm curious if like one of
the night falls will always be like a
year one and then the other two might be
more random because maybe they just get
one night phone they always get the year
one if you're new light and maybe if
we're we get the pic or if it's just
truly gonna be one strike
I'll be curious yeah because you see id
halo mmm
but I agree I think I think a card
things is he's done toasty yeah and
burned up on entry so the next thing now
this is a whole bunch of stuff to read
through so I'm gonna go through it and
then
go back and hit the points because we're
talking about progression and economy
changes this is all about levelling
level of drops over level under level
bonus all that type of stuff so I'm
gonna try and hit this in his basically
brief level that I can and then what
kind of hit the high points as quick as
possible
so all non powerful rewards now drop
three to zero points below your highest
equipment power up from 15 to 20 that is
a big one we'll get back to year two
powerful rewards have been changed to
legendary rewards these sources no
longer have a chance to drop it exotic
instead of legendary gear so no exotics
coming from old stuff will may be more
new bonus exotics that drop from
nightfall the ordeal will drop at the
character's highest equal power level
under and over leveling activities no
long no longer at just how much power is
received from the wards I didn't even
know that was a thing though you know
experience experience no longer fuels of
players character level which has been
to level 50 for everybody it's not even
shown on the screen anymore and I think
everybody's just level 50 it's just they
have to have something in that like data
slide ride experience instead progresses
the season pass season artifacts
progressed power progression as well as
unlocking of destinations for new
characters that's a kind of a little
clarification on that experience rewards
have been rebalanced with the
introduction of season pass and seasonal
artifacts everybody's probably gonna
worry about that one mmm the power
granted from the seasonal artifact is
additive to the power of players of
wobble gear but does not increase the
power of drops all existing this is like
one I was telling everybody cuz even
there were somebody I knew who came back
all existing gear has had its power
increased from a minimum or to a minimum
of 750 new characters will begin dusting
to at 750 do not infuse anything I'm
gonna say that before we can do anything
yeah do not spend a cord do not infuse
if you like something just wait just
wait
mmm season 8 power bands are as follows
floor 750 is where everybody starts soft
camp is 900 basically all drops will
continue to boost you up to that point
blues legend Ares you're gonna be using
them all powerful cap is 950 so from 909
50 non powerful pinnacle rewards are
capped at 950 pinnacle rewards are the
only way to raise power above
this point pinnacle cap is 1960 that is
the highest which is known as the hard
cap you cannot get a gear score above
960 that's gonna come from basically the
hardest stuff the nightmares the masters
the raid stuff like that hmm prime
engrams got some clarification and
changes prime engrams now gain charges
more quickly drop more frequently and
have a higher maximum charge cap 9 up
from 6 during year to the power gains
have been rebalanced due to the
increased frequency plus 3 instead of
plus 4 to 7 players who have completed
the primate example quest prior to that
game's release final family will earn
these charges but those charges won't
drop in the characters reach 900 this is
so people who are getting like blues for
the soft cap aren't waiting wasting
prime engrams on that which I my game
which is yeah because it was a strategy
involved yeah so alright that's a lot of
crap that's a lot of changes it's a lot
so to start at the top all non powerful
rewards drop three to zero points below
your highest powerful power level up
from 15 to 20 okay I'm gonna let you
tackle these first and I'll get my
thoughts on the end because I said
everything but what do you think about
this this already I've got thoughts but
go I'm not gonna be as this is this
isn't this is something I feel um is a
natural progression I really don't feel
like negative about it is one of those
things where it's like ok 3 to 0 points
below your highest equippable power
level you know I'm saying and that's up
from the 15 to 20 so you know to me this
is all with that steady grind right that
steady increment the ANA I'm for that
because you know you want things to help
you during this power clock so you know
well everything help you know there's
gonna be times when you're gonna get the
boots it's gonna be you know the boots
underneath by 3 years that I get that
but there's gonna be there's times where
you do get something in a place that's
needed and whether it be the you know
character mark or whatever a class item
and it helps you know so I think it's
that that incremental help that
discourages bad rng on your power climb
no because a lot of people really get
frustrated like damming these arms and
if you get arms you could be 15 I mean
you really
Trulli could get screwed and be like 15
power levels behind by your arms and
they're just dragging you down it is
just directed I've seen it it's you can
get extremely unlucky and that's the
difference between sometimes getting
ready for Pinnacle content and a rated I
don't ass at it that's so that's what I
got on it I think it's I think it's cool
you know I'm curious to hear your
thoughts on it
you know I'm saying as far as where
you're at I mean for me I'm definitely
down for I think it just makes
everything feel I think as you said you
described it well it's just gonna make
it all feel better you're not gonna have
you know major gaps in power level even
if like a blue possibly drop set you
know two or three power levels below
that still could that's still good to
keep that smoother progression as you
climb it's just gonna like smooth out
that thing where you don't know this
like if you look at all of your pieces
of gear on like a line graph you climb
that chart there's not gonna be this
flat line of your boots and so you jump
up big and finally get something so no I
think it's gonna smooth out everything
it's just gonna make it feel better for
newer players and stuff like that and as
a black iron man said it's like you
killed me by saying that out loud by the
way but after we'll have to watch it
after watching Hobbs inshallah that's
all I could make but it's just gonna
smooth it out but we have as he said we
have a hundred and fifty power levels to
climb in five days really it's for
because it's yeah it's 96 hours if that
helps you at all but it's a four total
days that you get to play 150 power
levels yeah and then maybe in there your
artifact got you 20 maybe even got some
other things to happen but 115 power
levels is still like a lot of drops for
every salon for every weapon and then
you can think as like I will say for
everyone out there
please do not infuse anything till
you're 900 yeah yeah I don't care if you
like your weapons leave them alone for
ya you know no but this is everybody's I
give your language yeah you're not gonna
not infuser you're gonna infuse no no
I'm gonna try my best to listen that
yeah yeah puts them put the favorites
away set them in the vault said just
leave them off the character and just
cycle through the random drops if you
get a blue auto rifle guess what use it
for a little while because you'll
probably get something else
a little while but that's the ideas do
not infuse until you are 900 because up
to that point a blue cutout level what
you just infuse which is gonna be a
waste of course you're gonna they're
gonna be so valuable so mmm year too
powerful rewards the Sun I want to I
guess see your to palaver award sources
have changed to legendary or rewards oh
how I gotta comment these sources no
longer have a chance to drop a random
exotic instead of the legendary gear so
basically anything I guess that's like
Kenny you're too powerful whether it's
forges whether it's other things you
won't be getting exotics from those what
is what are your thoughts sir yes of all
about this you are huh no oh yeah no
slow down it remember we have a battle
past too many yeah that's it high you
can get kognito to shut up
on this battle class is your nerf the
dam drop rates into the ground and I
love this this just nerf nerf nerf this
thing all the way I'm about feel like I
want you to get one exotica months damn
it that's right man did you earn these
and what blood sweat and tears into
these exotics that's right that's right
so I'm about all of this right here when
I saw that big smile because let's be
real jesse has a ton of powerful Engram
sources maybe powerful what tons tons
everywhere in the map star star star
star star star star all over the map
right so let's get that back in check
you got your battle pass if you get
unlucky and let's get down to making
these exotics feeling specially that's
gonna be the theme today I was gonna let
you know continue fair enough
bonus exotics that drop from the
nightfall the Oro deal will drop at a
character's highest equippable power I
mean I think that's so that's that's an
exotic that's not actually gonna give
you a power boost actually it's just
gonna be at your high at your highest
power so you're not going to get like
your exotics not gonna help you I guess
his way what do you think about that cuz
I mean if I go dude nightfall the ordeal
and I'm like 9:30 and I do it 9:20 and I
we get something with 9:30 it's not
helping me so it's almost do I just want
the legendary instead of the exotic yeah
you coming with that I mean I'm kind of
different I mean I get I get that point
I get that bone so you doing a knife
full joint get the drop bone I'm not
like either wages well as you are you
like against it like where you have I
mean I just feel like as they kind of
talk about other stuff I mean every like
powerful years gonna always like take
you up a few levels and things like that
I always feel like if you get exotic
into challenging activity and nightfall
the Orioles not gonna be easy right I
feel like you should get a little boost
from it something not just like if I'm
9:26 my exotic drops at 9:26 not like
even 927 would be like how cool I got a
little higher like something so highest
equippable Paulo right yeah like if I
can if my career if I look at dimming my
max levels 926 from everything I own
fault and character and otherwise and
it's 926 and I go in there at 926 and
then I fight that stuff and it drops at
the same level you're still cool without
a boost I hear your point I guess it is
interesting that they're doing this with
the bonuses I write from that that
terminologies we're done yeah
like the sentence sounds strange you
know they say I don't know why they felt
the need to kind of kind of single that
out yeah that's it just it feels like a
strange bullet point yeah that's what
I'm still wrapping my head as to my
thing is I'm also about like why Bungie
makes the decisions they make right so
for me I'm like okay why do you feel
then to cap that exotic right like why
do you feel like that was an issue kind
of deal I don't know those are kind of
things I think about when when I see
something that seems a little bit
peculiar I don't know about you what but
that's where I'm at what is it's a
little strange
I'm not like angry but it's just like
why yeah it's just odd I guess I mean
I'll have to see and mostly exotics are
gonna be like you know
they're gonna be more like what they do
not the level they are generally but I
mean if I get something it's just me
it's one more thing to infuse and I
guess when you get that bet nine hundred
and nine fifty is where I know some
people get frustrated is in that like
power grind and you got to hit the
powerful rewards and then you're limited
here and you can't get all this stuff
and you get what you go through and do a
nightfall I don't want to be saying I
wish I would have had a legendary
instead of an exotic and gotten a level
out of it that's I guess like oh we but
here's what they mean by bonus exotics
we know the way we're reading it wrong a
second one or something a second one
right so that meant if you if I get to
and one of them's not like higher that's
fine but if it's just your drop then I
guess that's where we'll have to say we
have to say yeah
and this is what I was like as we were
reading through I literally had no idea
this was a thing under and over leveling
activities no longer just how much power
is received from the rewards so I don't
know if you could get late
I know prime engrams give you a decent
jump but I mean even normal engrams
powerful will give you some boost if you
were under did you get a bigger boost or
I don't know it's weird
I don't know anyway just probably gonna
be pretty standard across the board
experience so we no longer have a player
level
everybody's fifty it's just some data
thing behind the scenes that they don't
care about mmm experience will make a a
this is artifact stuff yeah you see all
that stuff is turned in artifacts yeah
you know going so experience goes into
your season pass for your ranks your
artifact for your bonus power and power
progression is all those things
experience rewards have been rebalanced
this is the one everybody's like oh oh
no is it gonna be harder to get those
season pass ranks so we have to pay for
them oh no no do you do you think that's
gonna be a big deal or do you think
they're yeah I mean they've been
rebalanced for the in with the
introduction ask it's seasonal artifact
progressions I mean again we'll have to
see but they're at a point right now
with this such under the Microsoft
especially after XP gate they are not in
any position to be doing any tomfoolery
thing this community with our magnifying
glass whenever there's any
type of you know something that's
peculiar we call out quick yep crazy all
existing powerful gear going to 750
that's just don't infuse anything every
character every piece of gear every
armor every weapon everything in your
vault every single thing that you own to
your account is 750 just remember that
don't infuse save it mm-hmm
all right so here we got the power band
so everybody 750 soft cap 900 the raid
is 890 for the first encounter so what
you think is a soft cap continue to the
raid I like it you do I like it because
it's gonna encourage more of the
blueberries to get in you know I'm
saying and let's try to start it yeah at
least try to start it and that's the
problem always been entry for the raid
right at least if you give them a taste
and leave them that direction they may
stick around you know say I actually
like that that idea powerful cap is 950
so that'll be powerful rewards just like
we always see on the map like any of
your milestones you need to do are gonna
help you through here mmm
pinnacle cap is 960 that will be the
gear from just the hardest stuff I'm not
I'm assuming it's like masters and raids
maybe legend still but I mean it's gonna
be the hardest stuff to get you that
last ten in gear and that is truly gear
score only love it love it and then
we've got prime engrams now these are
getting some changes so they charge more
quickly because you'd always say is like
hey you're prime attunement or whatever
sitting there waiting right if you're
playing a decent amount so charge more
quickly and drop more frequently and
they're gonna give you a +3 power boost
which will be which is gonna be nice but
it is down from 4 to 7 but if you get
them more frequently they're kind of
figuring metal kind of balance it out
mm-hmm I don't know what the prime
example quest is what is it interesting
I don't act like I don't remember that
is that prior to shadow keeps release
will earn but that says before shadow
keeps released like I feel like we
almost have had that at some point like
an existing thing that I just don't
remember yeah didn't pay attention to
the name
but the big thing is like as we're
leveling up to the soft cab anything's
gonna help you so you save your 9
charges of priming grams as you level up
and then they're kind of gonna send them
out at a little quicker pace to get you
a nice little boost so I mean if you get
up if you can get to 900 teams is get to
900 get all those Prime's of drop so you
can actually get those types of boosts
mm-hmm
so what is like what is your plan like I
don't know how much you're gonna have a
chance to play and now you got work I've
got time off just cuz I chose to take
the time but what do you think what do
you think is like an optimal plan what
is your thoughts on like leveling up
what activities do you do are you just
gonna just like grind out public events
again like what are your what are your
thoughts oh I see these it to me eyes
I'm going a different approach man I'm
not normally old-school Cognito go hard
the most efficient sources I'm just
gonna enjoy it man
I'm gonna take it a different cuz now
that I've seen the soft cap is 9 I can
get in there you know I'm saying so I
mean I'm not necessarily going going for
world's first another that stuff but I
do want to experience the rake so I
think for me it's like I'm just gonna go
with the flow over I'm not gonna put any
undue pressure on myself I want to
experience different things I just want
to have fun with the content you know
I'm saying more so so um you know if I
long the way if I find something fishing
you be damn well sure you know there but
um yeah right now it's just more about
storyline finishing the campaign you
know seeing what these new activities do
and bring you know obviously at that
pseudo Forge thing I've got the name of
it off top you remember right I've
looked at screenshots but we'll know
quickly you know whatever I'm just gonna
enjoy it man I just really really you
know especially because the soft cap
allows us to get in raise 890 sore caps
9 there I can kind of chill I don't have
to go crazy I'll jump in the rain just
to see get a feel you know and then it's
gonna be contest rules or whatever so I
don't got to go crazy like it just gave
me a chance to breathe a little
I just want to enjoy me what about you
you you go I'll call boots to the ground
I mean I just I've got time so like I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be down for about
four or five days I've got one little
blip like I work from Saturday morning
one shift up till like basically 11:30
so if I want to do the raid I may not
start exactly at noon and I'm not trying
to like race the people but I mean if
I'm at decent power Louisville I
wouldn't mind trying to get a group
together I mean just to see how it goes
maybe get it done but I definitely will
talk about the rewards you can get from
that thing yeah I don't know if I'm
gonna go for the 24 hours that one's
rough cuz the contest rule they always
set you to like your fire team's gotta
be fire in you got to be on money like
seeing what's up so I'm gonna what my I
wouldn't mind trying but that first like
10 day window or whatever it is I
definitely want to get in for that and
we'll talk about that a little bit later
oh yeah well your well your xbox
brethren let you have some freedom over
to pieces I got cross see I move it is
just you know okay okay see I'm saying
hi like hey forgotten about you guys
it's nice though let me do the royal
wave
you say hi to the common folk listen but
you know you got five or six you try you
really trying to run it yeah absolutely
mm-hmm so yeah that'll be so I wouldn't
rob ibly started like noon but if
somebody's willing to like hey give me
like an hour to have some lunch get home
and be saying yeah I'll be able to put
some effort in you can rock with you
guys yeah Saturday Sunday something like
that for sure and even if it's late and
if it's not contests you still get
another week after which is nice so you
get you get some time in there because
it's gonna be on the fifth which will be
Saturday and you have until the 15th to
get like some of the cool stuff so
you'll have another full weekend to go
for stuff so they're giving people a
window which is kind of forgiving and
nice which I'm down for yeah but I mean
like when I think about leveling up I
wonder does the soft cap of 900 say
you're gonna go run public events
because they're one of the quickest ways
to get gear drops when everything's
gonna help you is that I mean I know
people are going to want to get
experience as fast as possible to get
their artifact quickly as soon as they
have their artifact
gonna start getting experience for that
as fast as they can but then also going
from 750 to 900 is a climb and just the
quickest way you can get anything to
literally drop whatever it's weapon
armor blues purples doesn't matter I'm
honestly wondering if lay people are
just gonna be farming basic quick stuff
as opposed to hey I'm gonna go try a
nightmare hunt my butt up my honestly
guess like the nightmare hunts are gonna
be like powerful gear you're not gonna
want to do those until you get to 900
anyway because like if you do it in that
first five days you're gonna want to
save those until that caps hit so it's
almost like matically so this is where
I'm wondering it's like are you almost
incentivized not to do the new stuff so
you save the powerful drops for nine
hundred see that's where I start
wondering in my mind is like I don't
know because if you can go to nine
hundred I mean it was just like playing
through the campaign yeah you'll get
some drums play through the campaign
unlock stuff try and get at least seven
on the artifact wins once that piece is
done once people have an artifact and
they can just like get natural
experience I was like I'm wondering if
like they'll you know mess stuff up I
don't know if you do like ten public
events at a road you get less experience
did they ever do something like that at
some point yeah I feel like really Kay
let me remember
cleared away from like come on two
different activities one senator was
addressed in at wob from an experience
standpoint that they wouldn't you know
they would put it put it pretty much
they were cognizant of what we were
doing yeah yeah we give a less
experienced addition like if you go run
a strike and then do do a couple public
events over here let meet your friends
on this other planet you'll be natural
but if you're just like running the loop
on EDC for example I feel like you don't
get quite as much out of it so some of
that maybe like merits you to like maybe
go run strikes or play crucible and play
game but like go do some things but also
when you think about like what are your
daily rewards what are your weekly or
it's like I don't want to grind out my
weekly strike playlist powerful gear
award if it's gonna be something I want
to save until nine hundred so then where
the hell would wait like it's just I'm
kind of curious what's gonna be good to
do and what's gonna be worth saving
because we don't even have a weekly
reset this time to reset that stuff
plagued we said that day it's not like
forsaken to me I just love to me the
greatest thing about this cap stuff for
my pain against off cap part
fan and pinnacle cat part I'm a huge fan
because I love the pinnacle activities
giving those rewards to get you to that
level and it's not gonna be anything
else but that is gonna force that
engagement get people into these hogs
activity is nothing worse than firing up
you know trying to get some people
together to do clinical activities and
no one's doing them because the ones is
you know of light I don't know how so I
mean that was always to me and I guess
this is where my issue with the pinnacle
activity including iron banner mm-hmm
because to me that's one of those that's
mm-hmm you there's not like if there was
something like trials if there was a
slate true skill based activity to get
you from nine fifty-nine sixty knows pvp
I'd be okay of trials was in there even
if I never got it yeah if I had to go to
lay and so if I had to go do crazy
master night falls or something that
would be my way and then someone else's
way is over here at trials or you know
believe I'm asking you about the weekly
reset wait no weekly no there should be
a weekly reset there's not a weekly
reset before the raid starts is alright
what he's saying yeah yeah so it comes
out on Tuesday the rate is Saturday so
we don't have a chance to reset powerful
drops from like run three run three
strikes run you know run five crucible
matches run gambit run game it probably
all those powerful Ziff you do them as
you're leveling up you're not gonna have
those as powerful drops at nine hundred
right so that's my idea there is that
saving like your normal stuff that you
might go just naturally do you might go
sit and run just like that's why I
wonder is like is it public events is it
picking a strike on a planet is it how
do you avoid how do you avoid those
playlists where you want to save those
powerful drops for as late as possible
but if the here's another thing to we
have to think about is that if the
primes are gonna be increased in
frequency just by the natural at least
it'll be natural grind in bro because
you just gonna you know hold on to them
and rock out I mean that that's dude
that's the bottom I'm getting the chin a
frequency and that's just literally game
play no matter what you were doing
really yeah I just don't know if like
well maybe okay so fine if you want to
run strike playlist then those are
decently like rewarding you might be
able to run those
I wouldn't like clear out every weekly
activity you if you're going for the
raid that's all I'm saying people are
trying to be as optimal as possible you
might want to save some of those like
weekly powerful in Gramm type drops for
later but you're like hey I'm gonna be
running crucible for like four days
that's what I'm gonna get my like so I'm
gonna get my drops dope like stay there
say strikes maybe for black wants you at
nine hundred or vice-versa
yeah I'm getting the way this appears to
be structured is look do what you wanted
you save those and powerful was like you
said so you get to that that wasn't a
nine nine hundred and then nine hundred
right you save those four then right you
continue to grind in the activity that
you like unless we find something super
efficient you'll get the slow steady
creep and you'll get priming grams and
work on your artifact right because your
artifacts gonna give you that plus two
whatever your you know your level cap is
so I think that's the vibe it seems to
go right now
and again if that's the case I'm okay
with that no excuse me have to see it
all in action but it will be curious
what people eventually light on when
you'll have four days they'll probably
quick on it'll be in like 24 hours
people are gonna like not sleep it but I
mean we'll know pretty quick with the
fastest way is but I just will be
curious what it what it lands on yeah
changes to bright dust bright dust is
now earned by completing crucible gambit
and Vanguard weekly and repeatable
bounties so choose to grant all of
bright does some ritual weekly bounties
rather than spreading it across weekly
and daily bounty so players could more
easily earn brightness without having to
make sure they complete every single
daily every day that's what they're kind
of getting out there'd be like just to
your Weasley's you'll get them
eventually don't worry about like
logging in every day just play some yeah
that was it
players were able to do the repeatable
bounties as many times as they like I
don't think they've ever had repeatable
bounties are they I don't know our
weekly is gonna be repeatable like is
that I'm I guess I don't know what that
implies to because I don't remember if I
pick up a daily it's done until the next
day if I pick up a weekly and I turned
it in I gotta wait till reset so I don't
know what a bounty is gonna be yeah
unless it's just like the dailies that
passed through but maybe that's a new
type of bounty
I don't know a school players will be
able to do any camp this this is one
thing that made the entire world
yesterday cheer I saw people like I mean
they're Chevy's the glads the I have
gigs like all the people who are like
dude let's just like not have this
insanity
oh man I'm all I do say I will kind of
feel sorry but I didn't do the grinding
so I was like I wasn't gonna worry about
it and I'm very glad so doing any
crucible gambit or vanguard bounties
completed complete any of those bounties
that are completed need to be turned in
before maintenance begins because as
these changes will reset on those
bounties they will not matter so if you
have like 10 of each bounty saved up on
each character they're all gone question
yeah I see I read about ease a bit I
have a couple of those but I got I've
seen I read about easy I'm just I don't
know I feel like they already like
nerfed iron banner Browning's before
honestly but honestly I have like a
couple I was just gonna save them to see
us like maybe I'll get the next season's
iron banner here just for entertainment
value I was gonna save them just for
that if they go away they go away but
I'm not I'm not worried the biggest
thing is like gunsmith bounties don't
get you much they get you cores which is
fine keep those ever versus bounties get
you ever right dust they'll talk about
that a little bit lower those are fine
but anything to save you up experience
and people were like hey I want to hoard
all this stuff so I have as much
experience so I can just go into all
three of my characters and like click
like click click click click and be like
oh I'm level 7 already cool it's not
there and I am happy about it real talk
he had to have a shot the chat is lit
right now logo vertebrae like yet Java
had except listen it had to happen
this was the hustle that everybody was
doing you know they're all the top tier
guys holding onto thousands upon
thousands of bounty and then come new
expansion blue buddy try to power they
way up past everybody it had to happen
but you know damn what I want ride him I
am banner bounty this is not only less
we go see if you know that is in effect
with like I play a little iron yeah I
played a little iron banner I had a
saved and those are all I will save so
uh missin crucible won't matter
I feel bad for you bender he said he was
saving his little bounty for reg Rick's
axe sucks because yeah I want you know
the pudding like 20-20-20 takes a little
while but if that's all if that's the
step that you're on playin no you know
it is play every day game crap five it's
it's a it's a time drag you know Brandon
just blaze out um what you call cool I
mean you got five you have five resets
in a season though so if you were trying
to save the bounteous for that the
resets are in there too so are your
resets done already maybes resets are
not done I don't know I was like so what
are they like the twenty bounties won't
be too bad it sucks if you're saving
them for that but yeah sorry
embrace gaming welcome to the show
you're saying so we don't need to grit
do all the grinding nope no save your
time you can go work on pinnacle
activities you can go work on our
pinnacle weapons you can go work on
random little stuff you can clear out
your vault which I've actually got you
would be proud man I have a hundred and
fifty slots in my vault right now open
you deleted gear had to leave did a lot
of gear I have like ten helmets in my
vault and that's it for all my character
it's not gonna hold on to all this year
armour 1.0 stuff oh it was so freeing I
was just like dad just start going I
have like I have a pair of gauntlets
that has like enhanced a rocket launcher
loader and rocket launcher scavengers
like I had to hold on to that for like a
few days today you hold on to that but
that but then I was like I've got like
because I mean okay for anybody who
hasn't seen my vault before fair fair
confession here absolutely horrid or so
but the thing is I would have liked a
helmet that had like machine gun like
machine gun what is the helm perks
because it got reserves and you got
reserves the helm will you be as far as
marketing so this is targeting lynching
this chill yeah it's like bonus
targeting so it'd be like machine gun
charging machine gun reserves okay yeah
like those sniper rifle targeting sniper
ever reserves fusion rifle target and
fusion rifle reserves
or whatever the super one fusion energy
into super and fusion reserves I had
every combination if I ever got like a
helmet that was like synergistic I kept
it because if there was ever a point in
the meadow shifted to be like hey fusion
rifles are God right now I'm gonna be
like go to my vault I got it good eyes
respect the move I was like thank God
everything so now I'm getting rid of it
because really the way oh yeah no he
looked at me and it was like oh my god
dude and I was like I know
[Music]
loco show logo that's a log Nets finest
man Lord the game we got net finalists
wait a minute he said wait a minute
didn't read drinks brownie disappear I
gotta switch out my grind today I got
two steps but you better get that that
you better get the mom bout he's done
yeah because yeah that part right there
is long man that part what he tells you
to you got to do 2026 like I mean if you
do five a day it's five for a s some of
the families are using mothers last week
Lori says five reset so big thing on
yeah so I mean the big thing about
Armour 2.0 you're gonna have a max need
like a minimum you would need three of
each three of three Helms an arc helm
solar helm and avoid ohm now you may
have an arc helm that is like this one's
heavily weighted to int disciplines like
all the other stats suck those two are
awesome and then maybe I'm gonna go in
PvP and I need one that's resilience
with mobility and I have a helm for that
but at max you probably need like two
builds for playstyles mm-hm so like I in
theory once you start unlocking most of
these mods for armor you really
shouldn't have almost any armor in your
vault
except maybe exotics you just don't need
at the moment that's literally about it
like I don't need 20 different Helms
because I can interchange everything at
will yeah once i unlock the mods and I
ultimately get on wait for that it's
gonna cut down on fall space
tremendously just like you said having
that flexibility and then we'll get into
perks a little later you know but it's
almost 100 is going to save a lot of
vaults a shadow for you for being
responsible and cleaning your attic and
stop being an old cat woman wow man I
went downhill fast crap yeah you you
were ridiculous Larry I get it Brady day
kind of situation well bro
it was a little much so thank you we had
our we had our listener intervention of
glad it had it had to be done had to be
done
yeah so I'm going through yeah my Titans
running like I got space on my character
my characters not running as like space
right now I got room to pick stuff up it
is glorious right now I'm running out I
should have been for forever but they
finally gave me a reason to get rid of
all this stuff and honestly for anybody
who is listening to this hasn't played
destiny to in a while may not have
picked it up maybe new to destiny too
that is why this is literally the best
time to play this game because every
single person does not have armor 2.0
doesn't have the armor 2.0 mods now they
may have an advantage on you on weapon
mods that's a thing but in armor and
most of your drops like we're all
starting half of our characters mostly
from scratch
yeah an artist cool just just cool one I
saved it just for that new light
all my nude st guys they're the most
intimidating thing as a new player is to
be like yo that's the new expansion it
looks cool man I want to play with you
Cognito
yeah and then they get anything like
alright you're only 500 light so you go
do the whole campaign we're gonna play
the new stuff and then you get back to
us like that you've already disconnected
the base the new players like come on I
want to play with you so you mean to say
I can't do the new content with you
now in light poles 750 boom they're
experienced in Alma 2.0 just like we
don't with you yeah I can't even I could
make a speculation video on armor 2.0
but I'm really gonna have to wait until
I get my hands on it because we're all
gonna get to see it do I mean I've got
an idea for most of it for what the
experienced if it holds true but
generally like yeah we're all seeing
armor new yeah we're probably gonna have
some weapons ahead of you but we're
gonna be picking up the new Astra shaman
weapons that glow for certain reasons
we've got we've got new exotics to earn
you so I mean there's like more you have
three weapons you have an artifact and
you have five pieces of armor six of
your six of your nine slots on your care
everybody's starting over you should
faculty today is finally gonna give me
Luna faction boots and then they're
gonna go to hell yep yeah if I Eve no
bun she's known for that too they
probably would he's gonna say she's
getting Luna faction foods
Orpheus rig boots and what would be a
good thing for Titans anything related
to you gotta get that barricade are you
good yeah barricades going that's just
class so this is class yeah mmhmm yeah
so but yeah I think this is probably the
best time and they couldn't have picked
a better time to launch new light for
anybody to come in because there's there
is so much though we're all gonna do
together
yeah the raytrace may not happen for a
blueberry but they're not gonna know
what's that happen anyway so I wouldn't
imagine they're gonna be trying getting
in there but they I think that's really
really cool yeah yeah I think again and
I Hampton - I think there will be the
cool thing about us being around but
hoarding those synergistic 1.0 is there
gonna be some builds that can kind of
power us through harder content because
we have that older stuff that again it
just has a little better synergy until
we unlock on 2.0 so we might be able to
get through harder content a little
faster than they might be because of
those bills yeah little stuff like that
but I mean generally it's at some point
you and that's kind of the thing I
wonder is the weight of is your enhanced
like Michael of certain for example my
in is my enhanced rocket launcher loader
and scavenger worth not being able to
use an artifact mod right because the
new mods from the artifact only are
gonna work in 2.0 where I new mobs like
in the old mods you've got her going
away so so no I honestly can't wait for
all this stuff hey but yeah cleaning the
slate on the bounties I saw that come up
and people were just like tweeting like
crazy the big Raiders and stuff we're
like yeah cuz even it was like Grenadier
Jake I remember he got his boost because
he was I think he maxed out for one
expansion in dusty won by getting like
turning him a hundred exotic engrams or
whatever insane a it was
so he could max out his character Wow
so that was like he did that and I think
infusion or something and he maxes out
his character in like four hours I think
ever more he was unlike fireteam chair
like what did you do and like I remember
that being kind of a boost that you used
even like alright can we really stop
this and they didn't so like there's not
a person out there who's like use the
system for what it is that's not like
yeah this is how it should be so yeah
absolutely I mean like a ferrous fit
it's just what it so we've got ever
verse items no longer semana Linda
bright dust instead grant legendary
shards and glimmer new ever verse items
for season of Laden diamond will become
available for bright dust two weeks into
the season so we're gonna kind of hold
off a little bit on some of the adverse
new stuff neveress items no longer
require bright dust to acquire them from
collections which is actually really
nice instead they cost the same
materials that reward items of the same
type and rarity used so charge plumber
basic stuff like everything else
fireteam medallions I don't ever use
these things these are going away the
boons are gonna be cheaper just normal
stuff for the ever verse that makes
sense and you won't be Brian all the new
stuff at ever verse for a couple weeks
that's basically it I hope they make
good gleam in a wizard that a crew boom
a gleaming crucible thing the one that
you gotta wait until you actually get
any gleaming boon of the crucible
yeah that's cheaper anyway that's yeah
they're weird
I have like five thousand crucible
tokens anyway it's ridiculous I don't
have much of a purpose form but yeah
immerse the season seven best of your
one ingram has been retired that's kind
of what we've been getting this season
and in its place Pierce can now obtain
the new season eight nostalgic Engram
the seasonal milestone will no longer
grant a bounty mmm seasonal milestone
will no longer go down and say that it
correctly glance a bright Ingraham hmm I
don't quite know what my soul is don't
remember what that was right now the
season eight nostalgic and grim is no
longer earned at level up now this will
be kind of different as you level up you
used to get that instead the bright
ingram is now included in the free
rewards of the season pass that are
visible before level 100 so
awarded every five levels after 100 so
do you think it's actually gonna feel
like we get less from ever verse now
this is all battle patch stuff again
every five levels after 100 it does seem
like it's spread out it definitely does
feel like to spread out in that inning
you know so yeah I would agree it does
feel a little less I'm getting a lesser
feeling yeah I have to see an action but
yeah I'm thinking that yeah it's just
gonna be a little slower I mean I guess
like I got a lot of stuff from the ever
verse previously I mean it was kind of
generous and I guess their store fun is
it's going to the director is meant to
be maybe a little more of a storefront
as opposed to here they're gonna give
you some but yes probably gonna be a
little less people are gonna be like oh
no people freaked out I'm sure people do
math somewhere figure out what we used
to get this much for playing this much
this out last time and I'm gonna now I'm
getting only these and it's like oh my
god why am I getting so many few yeah
yes coming yep the ever restore front is
on the director though that's actually
pretty cool just easier to get to the
tower I don't know if like Ava's just
like cleared out of the tower there's
just an open space sign be like I'm in
orbit I don't know I went to lunch those
space storefront I went to luncheon
space balls you can catch me at the
diner
ever verse bounties have been deprecated
as well any remaining bounty notes can
be broken down into bright dust they
break down into five each one I have
about 300 of those to break down so I'll
be breaking them down for a minute you
can still do bounty every burst values
for the last couple days so if you got
anything to work on you can knock them
out
but yeah everywhere some bright dust is
getting some changes but mostly good mmm
glimmer players can now store up to 250
K I don't know if you're doing the light
ship farm thing where people have like a
hundred ships in their gold did you get
did you get the Platinum solid on a baby
blacksmith ship did it man I'm so proud
of that shift
if you got all that space in your vault
go stick like 100 of those things in
your vault and then and then just like
break them all down and cap that glimmer
on day one
and one day one facts
I gotta get in there right let's tile be
really funny they change that thing up
to give you guys like one legendary
shard see why you got four did you know
they'd post them stop be like hold up I
put this one ship there's like 100 of
these ships and every result what the
hell is this oh oh no let's just make
this ship worth like one legendary this
is a say that'd be brutal but yeah Thank
You bender yes man I'm proud of my
little evil ship I love that [ __ ] man
mm-hmm
glimmer Awards from the majority of
sources in the game have been rebalanced
most open-world sources public events
lost sectors chats have been
significantly increased which is nice
actually
bloom are being a little more valuable
using it for infusion if you run by a
chest I actually might go open the damn
thing now cuz usually yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah
passive glimmer gain on go ahead no just
going to say there were times when you
are broke and it's like you kind of want
a nice little source if I farm you know
some public events in something now
maybe I can get some cash up you know to
get what I gotta get good there are
those times when you do the normal
people not evite you know you go through
some tough times with glimmer you botch
this with no he doesn't nobody oh my god
but I like this y'all hit them public
events hate them ball sack this glimmer
games will be increased and then you can
go see the next character we'll talk
about after this uh bullet point yep
in addition to directly awarding glimmer
on kill combatants will sometimes drop
additional glimmer chunks as you're
running around picking up glimmer on the
ground that little blue stuff will
actually mean something and we leave
bounties reward a large amount of
glimmer in addition to their other
awards that's nice weekly bounties have
a little bonus on top of them they're
trying to give us more reason to earn
more ways to earn glimmer because we're
gonna be spending it more frequently it
sounds like so all in all just kind of a
kind of a fair exchange it seems like
mm-hmm
spiders exchange loan exchange currency
exchange loan shark down in the dumps
that's the loan shark the spider
welcomes new opportunities with four
arms open and now
deals in materials from all planets are
you kidding me I can get rid of my damn
trees oh holy hell like this fight is
the hustler I love it let's go
however the Spyder has noted changes the
market value and it's just at his
exchange rate accordingly he's looking
at the stock prices he's looking at that
ticker the Dow Jones is up right now so
he's gonna got a change going on
employer coin is the mark you know man
his inflation is instant by the way
painful instant inflation like oh you
want this oh it's just got more
expensive I just bought ten of them well
now it's 20 now it's 40 what the hell
price it at the price of the dust locks
went up this week did man just like
shards is hot a Boop I hate oh yeah go
ahead hey hey my my farming we'll talk
about that later that was one of the
best oh my god I thought that was like
also good glimmer exchange now costs 10
legendary shards or 20 materials and
yields 10 dozen glimmer sews up from 5
so I think it's pretty pretty much the
same mm-hmm taking sure daily bounties
no longer a word glimmer providing
instead etheric spirals keeping with
this competition everybody basically
just Ward's planetary materials so he's
doing the same all right thank you for
saying that now the weekly wanted
bounties no longer award gear but now
provide between 3,000 and 15,000 glimmer
in addition to enhancement course
offered so I know there's wanted
bounties there's the the one big one and
one at the ends that was actually was
worth a piece of gear for powerful gear
yeah I wonder if that one's actually off
the table too
that's a good question because they are
like they're kind of pulling back on all
the powerful gear sources I wonder if
that one's just like yeah just a body
out there maybe that's the 15,000
glimmer guy he's just a big one mm-hmm
traumatic has over 25,000 dust light
shards from finances I stopped it like
8,000 I figured I was fine but holy
health I guess if you want to let it
we'll shoot we know what you were doing
yeah sleeping on the job literally
exactly good today all right so yeah
spiders exchange you'll definitely be
able to he's just yeah he's currency man
just go in there mix stuff up finally
mr. szura mystile typical face pan
SURS inventory pool and faded Engram now
includes world drop exotics from year to
so any armored world drop exotics from -
does that include because if you say
world dropped technically like yotan
drops from the for juice right is that
still a world drop because it's not from
a quest can't be that gotta be long what
about layman art they can't be giving
out layman oxen and yotan s-- from faded
engrams new it's behind in a voyage
didn't get it the way it suposed to be
got either is giving you the common
stuff I mean when you get layman arc
it's literally just a drop from the
forge so it's a world drop it's just a
different activity Lord I know I just
don't know honestly I'll be curious if
anybody literally goes this era faded in
again Newton this is new I would I would
not be afraid of that over the ground I
had to do get you behind in black on
really good
hey for just open everybody you can
grind that crap like everybody else
exactly mmm-hmm yeah we will see but yes
mostly that's gonna usually include the
armor like liars handshake stuff like
that any of the new armor from the past
three seasons will be now in there some
more armor I say actually getting in
there than weapons patch notes preview
and there's some things that even the
Bungie devs are proud to actually be
putting in here number one rally banners
to Leviathan eater of worlds inspire of
stars whoa where's my spire star screw
it man and we got rabe anything I need
to sleep of catalyst come on you got
incentive now let's go I love how funny
like some of the veterans are in here
but like no that's the force no no yotan
took me forever you forged for it baby
wait thank you you put that work in out
to my own people don't be a par 5 that's
right I had it I got no tell them to get
Jerry not giving out freebies man you
gotta you got to do it you got to get
familiar with ADA don't you try to get
that stuff from sir hey Lord of wolves
came from zero one point I'm just saying
that is true that is true
so it's possible just well we'll see
the shattered throne dungeon is now
available at all times instead of on a
three week cycle and it can be launched
and reset from the director whoa big hey
somebody out here is like are you
running this on the weekly down are you
just doing like shadow throne carries
constant that's just my job now is like
shadow throne right nice backpack spots
jump in let's go alright we're done
let's reset alright let's go yeah you go
be YouTube and just get it get it get it
get in twitch telling you people are
looking for I got people on my friends
you guys I am a kind I have content to
make excuse me but like shadow throne is
seriously amazing so now it does take
forsaken light the Forsaken license you
have to own forsaken to play shadow
throne that is why I'm very curious what
the shattered throne package will cost
because they just ripped the annual pass
stuff out of it yeah
so now after cuz it what was it forsaken
and the annual pass was 25 bucks annual
pass is now gonna be with new light and
free I'm wondering what the forsaken
license is gonna hold because really all
this left and forsaken is basically the
few the exotics we had through the year
that were specifics they had like last
word
I think Lumina might have been in there
and then you have shattered throne last
last wish scourge of the past so
literally just buying raids
I wonder what like you're buying raids
in a dungeon so I'm really curious like
what how much do you think that should
costs come shadow keep because the
annual pass is currently in the twenty
five dollar item and now that twenty
five dollar items going to be basically
have less that it requires ten bucks
vagabond Oh a quarter of it I was gonna
be like I would say like 1999 15 bucks
10 like it I don't think it should be
much play can't be much enough content
to guarantee to generate to warrant dad
the subclasses are locked behind it too
that is true wait two subclasses of the
Forsaken subclasses are all in there so
you got nine subclasses no yeah you're
right some classes gonna get people to
buy cuz you gonna want that nose new so
yeah that's yeah that's actually small
marketing so but but what do you think
is a fair price if subclasses and
basically like raids shattered thrown a
couple quests like you're getting some
content but you've seen every year it's
not like I'm not buying an expansion now
I can go to the Dreaming city it's just
like there's not a wallet says baa-baa
excuse me
pom pom you don't have this yet right
they can't go no more than ten dollars
otherwise it's gonna be a problem
because it's still older content it was
like it's got like I agree the between
our Father $10 ranged I say ten because
again our baby is in there yeah I can
see 10 yeah Matt it should not be more
than 15 that'll dump is 15 is kind of
pushing feels steep but that is the
highest I would say like you could go
you should go like cuz you take the
annual pass out of there that's that's a
good chunk of year I mean annual passes
you're gonna be getting basically
because you have game bed wrecking
that's a whole piece of the annual pass
you have Menagerie already on there you
have the forges in there so literally
you're gonna get crown of sorrow an
exotic quest scourge in the past and an
exotic quest and then last wish and
shattered throne yeah it's like six
things that's not that much it should
not be that expensive and it's older so
I paid $10 so shadow throat alone that's
true I would pay 20 bucks for shadows
probably the last wish alone that's my
favorite so yeah so I mean it's I'll be
very curious how that adjusts come
October and if they give it a little bit
then people get into it and be like
$12.99 I I see we got the the marketing
man and he's like alright we can work
with that psychology we got to keep it
under 15 but that $0.99 get its us a
little bit more 12 bucks that's that
middle range $12.99 yeah I did tags you
don't worry to make it free and this
rate yeah probably they probably will it
even like I think TAS he was like why is
everything in force I can just not in
there I don't know but I mean I know
there are certain things and they're
just trying to find some ways to help
with some income but yeah I just don't
think it should be that much if they
want a fair black armor forges are now
accessible through a director launched
playlist on the year
be in that zone finally thank you you
don't have to fly in and go to the
stupid cave and go to go out for burgers
eeeh yeah oh and then I got a Crouch do
this other one to go
is it not like are there rally banners
in the fortress please can I have like
rally banner and the shadow thrown in
the forges come on be nice weapon mods
are now treated as reusable unlocks
instead of consumables any mods you have
in your inventory will be converted to
unlocks if the only copy mod you have is
in a gun you Willits required that's
fair yeah some of the stuff we knew
discarding an enhancement cord no longer
deletes the entire stack I would have
just like I don't know why you would
delete any of them well here deleting
calls like that I think it's probably an
accident
people probably deleting something
something moved maybe I don't know but
I've heard people have deleted the stack
of course and I would probably just try
yeah now this is weird
yes polaris borealis and hard light now
matched the prism modifier when changing
elements on reload rotating through void
are consoler nice so it's like if it's
like oh we're in void reload and it just
goes to it yeah absolutely it works with
the soon as you know weapon makes it
yeah makes it a little more viable - so
you're not like a real it up wrong on
reload again crap enough that I've
missed it - and I'm like 6 reloads later
I'm like I'm useless right now you gotta
wait until agent absolutely fixed an
issue where the hunters tempest strike
male ability could not be performed if
the sprint button was set to hold weird
and little stuff you never know about
this won't ask you about take it yes
what do you got yeah a Phoenix Protocol
hearth Berk no longer only what health
alert by the way they're tight they're
type oh okay well no longer super energy
on kills and assists to warlocks inside
of a well of ratings if they do not also
have the well of radiance attunement of
great upgrades so classic red this is
interesting because that exotic when you
put on you you thought you well you get
kills you know while the well is there
you know it builds up your super energy
based on but you could run nova bomb
with Phoenix Protocol
standing else as well yeah that's
cheating the system so yeah that's the
ask Alex just wants a this is a to stop
an exploit that is what this is you know
that's that's that's fair
I'll give him that yes mm-hmm I fixed
the issue were allied golden gun
projectiles weren't going through banner
shields sure
oh no yeah just like holding up your
shield Golden Gun not going through it
Oh gotcha yeah that wouldn't be good
yeah
fixed issue where the Creek queens
wrath' perk for the exotic wish inner
boat wasn't correctly highly lighting
players if their shield was depleted
that's interesting players who have
obtained of the salute emote in the past
can now correctly select it in their
collection assign it to emote wheel
multiplier emotes will have a visible
indication of where to stand that's
actually nice because most people can't
seem to figure that out
yeah and the final one the biggest like
looked from Bungie the community has had
in a little while hahaha take this one
just because I want to hear you say this
with all the sass you can Oh boys we had
a good run y'all salute my man pyro but
we they got us with it we go to jail
that milk we can't like that brother
failing the first encounter for any
black Aubree Floyd's will no longer
award planetary destination materials
icon hilarious her left yo shout-out to
all my guys who had their pcs on for
nights on edge in the boys salute all my
console guys who had their consoles just
write a nice game just running shout all
the dust like shards of the data laces
up tear just filled up everybody's boy
what's a good run man we ate well come
on y'all well we we got a little fat now
like it was time you listen I have to
admit this is probably again shout to
peril this was probably one of the
greatest
easiest farms ever the facts you could
just go in there and walk away
yeah greatest day ever I wanted to fund
our hustles especially during season
opulence week Alice was out here while
I'm with deals materials remember
oh yeah some people whole he was acting
up so that not was necessary you had to
give him a tiger you're still a few days
72 hours left to farm no are going them
systems on you know if you don't affect
your electricity bill do what you gotta
do because you only got a couple more
days y'all get in there I want to see
all my whole friends list in the
ignition
everybody when you see your friend on
power level of like 450 70 like funny
about this I was when everybody found
out it was the funniest thing I ever it
was a good run and then also it's
definitely a rap because um everything's
going up to 750 anyway so those that we
were snatching from Hawthorne those got
to go up oh yeah everything's up so
there's no low level stuff in there
anymore or you're gonna have to fire a
fire team who's willing to sit there
weekend at the because you got a yeah I
got a piñas man get out of rich little
weapons and / changes in season of the
undying pinnacle weapons will become
ritual weapons they will no longer have
special perks and will instead be
curated roles a previous article
incorrectly show two new pinnacle
weapons the good news is you'll be
getting three ritual weapons but each of
the ritual activities crucible Vanguard
and gambit here's the Destiny dev team
on why we made this difficult decision
and some information on in an upcoming
part change destiny dev team the
decision to stop creating extremely
powerful critical weapons was made for a
variety of reasons the first was that
the band in which pinnacle / can exist
is actually quite small and most of them
far exceed the FC they should have been
at another issue is that they caused
problems in the player ecosystem
particularly in the case of the crucible
pinnacle weapons due to the nature of
pvp and PVE anything that works well in
pvp is likely going to be extremely
effective in PvP
as well who'da thought this forces
players into the crucible key sentence
show if they want the best loadouts even
the title of pinnacle set a variety of
unrealistic expectations boy rather than
being the absolute height of legendary
power they were supposed to be
interesting novelties to chase these
problems became more pronounced the more
of them we produced in the end we
decided to move away for Pinnacle
weapons if you manage to collect them
all we hope you enjoy them while we're
on the subject weapons and then they're
gonna get into some more changes but
let's stop here because this is the hot
one
shout out to Tassie shots of my boy Josh
raining we had a great article up on
once game that net about this um gear
man this is a hot one so we want me said
oh man you ready okay you start yes this
is one of your big baby so let me get my
drink
here's the thing protein shake I can see
it coming already all right here's the
deal yo this is tough I am torn I'm very
torn here here's the deal I understand
their logic right they're saying it got
a little broke if you run around here
mountain tops you know finishing bosses
doing stuff in PvE because it's sucking
its effectiveness in crucible translated
here's what I struggle with I get it I'm
not saying they're wrong people that the
balancing was getting a little out of
control with certain ones I guess for me
it's like when they introduced glory and
Valerie right when I heard about glory
and those pinnacle it made me want to go
into that activity now I wasn't playing
comp like that must be especially
especially when trials was removed yeah
right that gave me even less incentive
so then I'm like okay pinnacle weapons
this is a cool thing and let's be real
II
you was in there hard core I seen you
getting that mountaintop you know I'm
saying I know I feel people hardcore
getting those registers Lunars and
regardless to if they I'm gonna say if
they broke the game or not but I just
like the fact that it really created
engagement and an activity that for the
most part most people wasn't really
messing around with so again I worry now
with these things again I haven't seen
we're gonna get into the guns you know
later you know we're gonna get into it
with what the ritual ones are yeah but
it's just when you say curate it roll it
don't sound sexy right now
no again we haven't seen it but it don't
sound sexy it don't sound you know these
clear ready rolls better be like amazing
you don't say like you know it just
again I understand it where they getting
out of control
absolutely where people having loadouts
of recluse mountaintop you know say I
get it you know those they're very
strong weapon I'm saying so I'm sad to
see it go I understand why it went yeah
I was just hoping that they would go
along the route of maybe just nerfing
the effectiveness of paducah weapons a
little bit but my thing is this all we
legitly going to grind comp gambit for
these crucible rolls these curated rolls
excuse me that's that man what I need to
know tell ya they're not gonna be as
long of a grind they say they cover that
a little bit but I mean as you're saying
it's like what got me in to come
literally these things did I had no
reason to go in here and if you take
them out and if they're not that great
if I have a good roll from any other
activity in the game is it really are
they likely to be worthwhile a bashing
my head against this thing probably not
now you are setting up like comp to have
a solo queue and I was like cool what's
the new weapon at least I can go in
there spend some time in there but this
just gets back to a bigger issue of what
is the point of playing is PvP just an
arena without
rewards and the awards come from
somewhere else because then that brings
back like your main ask like worst
trials where is your main thought of
what is the elite activity in PvP that's
gonna get me something because I'm gonna
go bash my head against even in other
games that you like overwatch I mean if
you get into diamond rank you still get
to see or whatever these things are you
have something for it trees like your
your legend rank is just literally a
number basically only you can see unless
you're wearing an emblem there's no
ornaments there's nothing else that
comes from these places so you're that's
one of the things I mean shout-out to
low no say no to rage I mean is one of
his big things it's like incentivizing
your activities in some way or another
if a nightfall is gonna be brutally hard
I need a reason to run it same thing
you've been saying why haven't you been
a night falls I got no reason to go I
got is something even better why not
keep the pinnacle at the pinnacle
weapons if you're so concerned that they
break the game make them exotic they did
that with hammer make recluse and exotic
cuz my thing is this it's like you just
nailed it in again I got us I got it I
got arrived for my people like once
again PvP is getting the short end to
the state all the time bro you take
activities away then we finally get
something cool I do know that his thing
the PvP community looks at the PvE guys
like man they get 1,000 voices and they
I mean even though its orangey but you
don't seem like there are things you
guys can get by grinding and it's just
like this let's be really this was the
ultimate badge of honor one of the
proudest things I've seen was when you
put up the tweet you had all four joints
right superbrain he was bred out his mad
bread out I open my own bakery wonder
brave amazing like the man had the
recluse read Rick's mountaintop was the
fourth one to revise was the other one
well I got revoke or yeah kind of stuff
and do we agree with you know how long
these stuff yeah it took a while but man
it's when you got it you got it if
they're so concerned about it
I'm exotic but to throw curated feels
kind of cheap it feels cheap like I'm
not really going crying again in defense
of the money the city's weapon
if these rolls are like outstanding
maybe III question but it's just like
you it was so unique it was just like it
was just they were just unique they were
very cool and I'm sad that I mean least
they not getting rid of the ones we have
but I just sad that I was looking
forward to what the pinnacles would be
you know and it's just added we're not
gonna get that anyway I mean Hampton
said it in chat it's like compiz in a
tough situation you have like even
streamers and people that do carries and
help people get these things and that's
part of what they do you take the
pinnacle grind away it's like cop
becomes next to obsolete like I mean I'm
gonna have a solo queue playlist in
there but I need a reason to go what is
the reason what is the reason to grind
again you do the knife for for a
specific thing you do the REA cuz you
want a specific thing you know
everything has a specific chase item
you're now relegating pvp into a curated
role of something and again I'm trying
to be fair here cuz I haven't seen what
these roles are and maybe that it's
amazing maybe it's all my gut like maybe
Kendall KITT is in arm in black on
forest right I got the I can't wait
we're gonna talk about kill clip and
rampage minute but they got killed
Clavin rent kill kill cut the wrapping
this one the only hand cannons that can
run both right masterwork range it's
amazing it better be on this kind of
level well it better be like yo this is
powerful cuz you other than that's like
you know I don't know so we're gonna see
what this ritual is about but ya feel
good just tell you right man no it's
it's they had Pete cop had that's
literally most of what PvP had iron
banners minimal it's another shade of
armor I mean it's another little visual
thing iron banner had its own weapons
which weren't ever great you had a great
role on one of them just because it was
lucky spike grenades on swarm but PvP
really hasn't had that much I'm
our focus more on the seasons the art
the seasonal invasions that but it's
like PvP still part of the game and they
said they want to try to have more focus
on and this just feels shot out the
walls weird he just sails something else
which is what if the curity roles have
perks that can't roll together regular
right and listen they're probably going
to do that but then you also run a
situation I've seen this before where
sometimes their version of a curated row
ain't necessarily God room no yes so
this is again us trusting them to say oh
yeah this is the best version of it like
sometimes I've got way better versions
of a gun than what they considered their
God role purity role so you know well
we'll see I mean just again pvp
community man I feel free feel fresh man
and it's your out of your watch
Spartacus to the character Oh
once again yeah you always complain hey
that's his catchphrase if shots of
anybody who's less Spartacus ya know
Batiatus characters hilarity I always
feel that when it comes to some decision
you know said trials it's like once
again the PvP community gods and
forsaken us have done is dirty and this
how I feel man I mean shot again because
you guys are feeling it too you know you
know Vanguard stuff but I just hope
these rolls you know what else to last
point before our fish memory what was
cool was that like regice had desperado
a unique perk only that gun well use it
like these it man you know what if west
over fort was the Rekluse one was the
name man
man-at-arms some like that madam or
something like that again just these
unique cool perks it's just felt special
man and and I thought you know I thought
we was gonna continue that man it was I
thought it was a really cool thing just
again really so concerned about it
make it exotic you've done it before
you've done it with black hammer
you made the spindle make reclusive in
this way you force that choice so people
can't run all three at once right if
you're so concerned make mountain top
that exotic problem solved
promise I'll make him exotic could be a
thing I don't know yeah I could see that
doing so they did also following line
with what these curated rules are
potentially gonna have are some of the
purge that we're about to talk about and
some of these are gonna be changing so
then you worry like as the curator dearl
even gonna be as effective as they are
now don't know so they reduce the
effectiveness of the following perks in
PvE now this is PvE only by the way PvP
these things will still work so like
your recluse is still gonna step on
people all over the place in PvP in
general you've got the perks rampage
kill clips swashbuckler boom to kill
clip desperado surrended master-at-arms
onslaught that's most of our good perks
everything good yep in general these
perks use the same damage multipliers
for PvE
that they did in PvP the change to
rampage does not affect huckleberry nice
huckleberry is apparently gonna be so be
God mogul berries like just getting all
the extra bonuses in here yes arm slot
and desperado now changed bullet impact
values while active in PvE so like this
brought up see that's one of those it
fires so slow in PvE desperado does but
when it kicks on it feels really good in
PvE so you're like mmm have a good one
vagabond to check you later man alright
vagabond Oh solo surrounded no longer
multiplies precision damage on top of
base damage as it was benefiting some
weapon types more than others as a
result basically they say legendaries
have become too powerful overall in many
cases they even out class exotic primary
weapons yeah because most people run
exotic heavies and that's about it so or
energies but primaries don't get much
love so we're taking we're walking them
back a bit all the way back to original
destiny we had a park named crowd
control which was rampages predecessor
crowd control trapped capped out at a
buck craps
almost no crowd control crapped out and
a bonus of 15% extra damage at this
point it does need to rampage caps out
at about 67%
that's a 447 percent increase from the
original iteration it's like yeah that's
a little broken legendary damage perks
have become so powerful they simply
invalidate non and damage related perks
and I mean this is something any anybody
out there who's made a video about the
state of destiny has stated this like if
you don't run rampage kill clip and
anything but boost damage damage is the
winner damage is key so they're gonna be
bringing some things back and that's
really all they say they don't go into
full detail so some scientists are gonna
have to go out there and shoot stuff and
figure out what the things are gonna do
now
so now as your rampage stack of three
gonna be worth it versus other things
right I don't know that is the question
that is the question is damage damage is
still gonna weigh typically more than
most things though least ability um you
go through a list of perks and you're
like what else am I gonna use instead of
like I mean damage is still damage I
mean the same thing happened in division
there's so many different PDP sets
within division 2 it's like the only
thing that matters with DPS build am I
really gonna take like Zen moment and
what is the bottom of the mag that does
extra damage am I really gonna make
those like my primary things versus
anything else I mean like outlaw and
field prep it's like ooh I can reload
and I have more bullets or each bullet
does more damage like they need to start
talking about like what is your dps
looking like how much does a reload
matter on these weapons they're taking
away reload speed so
you're still messing with people's
damage and that's usually what's gonna
win so honestly my hunch from this from
the difficulties come just the game is
not gonna be easy
yeah but things are gonna those buffs to
miners last week
yep miners are gonna be more of a threat
headshots are gonna do less damage to
them and we we got the name plate
enemies and neat guys going up though I
don't know that the the name plate dudes
the high-level enemies today awesome
yeah remember what the whole level thing
oh we just won't leave mmm oh that's
just if you fight something over your
level but yeah
yo yellow no yeah I mean everybody's
gonna need every bit of damage they can
it sounds like
just gonna be harder to come by so this
would be very very interesting this is
they are making this game one that will
be a challenge in many many ways and I
don't know what the current player base
is gonna think about the feel of year 3
virzi or 2 you can probably you can go
into patrols they never feel threatened
you could run through places people are
probably gonna be dying a lot more I
have a feeling in that contest modifier
may not quite be worth the head bashing
for that 24 hours that I may let some of
the crazy ones figure that out before I
even try and step it I'll just be like
I'll level we'll try it on Sunday see
what feels mm-hmm take it light
I don't know I mean what do you think
about all this stuff yeah yeah let me
jump in um is it there like again are
they correct that legendaries have
gotten a bit much yes that we got if we
were being honest as that's the players
absolutely it's gotten to the point you
know that legendaries have gotten a bit
crazy you know I guess this is where I'm
torn you know on one hand I do like it
because it's like okay I'm looking at
stuff and I'm like for example berry
example okay yeah if you have an exotic
and exotic should be outperforming in my
opinion so way I look at it to the
output on a legend there it should be a
decision process right so I get I'm all
for them going back to that aspect I
guess you know where I struggle is if
you're gonna nerf all of these damage
perks right where is the balance on
other perks that don't get any attention
that are in dire need of above like I
don't see um what is it head seeker
there's other stuff that like literally
it's like it's it's ineffective it
really doesn't provide any choice it's
always gonna be kill clip swashbuckling
rampage over these things so again my
only issue it make the other things also
better so now we have incentive or if
they're unaffected they're ineffective
like you say like you know who's running
Zen moment in whatever whatever change
the nature of the purple yeah
I'm saying so it actually does something
that we want to do and that's always
been this love-hate relationship I have
with destiny sometimes because again I
understand the logic behind why they do
things but at the same time it's like yo
you've got all these other very average
mediocre perks that just need attention
the same way Armour used to need lean
attention it's like they're not there is
like they're soaked us all my god
they're breaking the game
there's too much kill click rampages -
ok cool get it but at the same time you
can also say you know what ain't nobody
really using you know whatever you know
whatever they back perk of the week is
because they like let's do that man and
that that that's all I'm saying you know
I do like the overall I think the
overall process will help the game
exotics will feel stronger yet there's
no doubt you Sam
but um yeah they are definitely going in
that direction I just I just wish they
could do two things at the same time you
know I mean I'm with you on that one I
wish there's a lot of perks on weapons
that still don't feel great and it's not
like they're buffing up a lot of those
they're taking stuff down and they have
been doing that stuff they've kind of
been alluding to it and some of the
stuff has been seen but also even if
some it's kind of what they said when it
comes to crown of masks of dire Ankara
okay mm-hmm
you throw a nova bomb you get some
energy back but now you get less than
you used to but you're still doing with
super energy which is ultra vailable
which but like get cyber I gotta stop
you right there
is it really terrible it is pathetic
okay it is a put like I test it just to
steal my out of feeling it's not even
worth running it is you run ahead right
now on 20 years or better - what's the
one huh Batman is come on y'all know one
that would you we're all void stuff it
gives you what NASA wrecks in okay the
Nazareth Nazareth's more effective
because um again if I run pretty much
all void stuff I'm getting super energy
fat and I'm getting ability recharge
rates faster so that's about supplement
but again they
they just nerfed you know they've made
that exotic almost useless again almost
it was like think they went with the
extreme hand almost like they did with
Nova war remember when no what was
running crazy and then they just wait so
far to the left if I crazy yeah mm-hmm
no I mean that's that's the thing is I
don't I don't know how they win this
battle because they don't want things to
be overpowered they always try and keep
things in balance some people are gonna
get done playing Borderlands and come
back and be like hey this thing's hard
as hell it Johnson been like playing and
there's all this craziness out there and
it's like they're afraid for things to
break it and understand when things do
but then when they smash all the good
stuff down and don't bring some of the
other stuff up I know there's a point of
power creep but somewhere there's got to
be a balance to walk and I just don't
know it there's not an easy way to
answer this question I understand what
they're trying to do when you have
recluse and mountaintop running every
rage just easily yeah like there there
is a problem there but in turn do you
never bring a Pinnacle weapon back here
you just make different perks I mean the
Vanguard pinnacle weapons never got much
love because they all kind of sucked you
can make those all day exactly make
pinnacle Vanguard weapons and none of
those get used
do you hear my point about the Audis
other perks though oh yeah I just can't
I don't want to go through like think of
all the lists of stuff but let me click
on a random guide and you're like a
grave-robber
melee kills reload a portion in this
magazine
I mean maybe for ask them jeez yeah it's
um that but they're just some things
that are just so think about it's almost
like the same thing with rocket launches
and across the cluster bomb like no one
you're not taking any other rocket
launcher perk the rocket launcher don't
got tracking and it don't got cluster
bombs or whatever you ain't taking it so
make some other things more effective
yeah like if cluster bombs is on there
and fires slower than other ones can get
out the grounds quicker like there's
like reload speed is slower and velocity
slower and cluster bombs they take
longer to get there but the quick ones
you can shoot out like three rockets and
you know quick just certain things
yeah sure Auto loading holster was
cocoon and d1 that was seriously yeah it
was cool now it's I don't even care so
they said here's a quick preview of the
three ritual weapons you can earn and
seasonably undying because these weapons
are no longer pinnacle to crest required
to get them as not as in-depth as
previous stuff hmm
we've got Vanguard which is Edie what
edgewise that's the machine gun mm-hmm
so it's actually good because another
machine gun source is not bad probably
almost gonna be a replacement for
avalanche but we'll have to see a
crucible
Randy's throwing knife which is the
weirdest name ever I don't understand it
looks cool I just like the almost like
ivory barrel and like the two colors on
it but yeah it's definitely Scout rebel
as well looks sexy to me
well it just looks exactly like
avalanche to me blue you got a game bit
exit strategy Kim do I have an exit
strategy don't join the match no hahaha
but Randy's throwing knife is the Scout
and an exit strategy that looks like
submachine gun you think yeah definitely
submachine guns getting a boost getting
a boost like this this one you may be
playing game but just to get a nice
submachine gun because submachine guns
are actually worth a while yes our
machine is gonna be really good in this
matter par 5 and they're everything
we've been doing lately any grind
anything you've been doing lately most
of it feels pretty easy next week it's
gonna change we'll just have to see how
these settle into the meta see if
they're worth it and maybe these are
more things people don't know life but
it's more just as you naturally pay
through it be like ah cool I got it
twice let's see how this goes maybe
they're just not as excessive of a grind
really like I'm gonna pull my hair out
work on a mountaintop but if I do get
this crucible scout rifle yeah it feels
pretty good fires fast got a good combo
perks on that no one's there some people
in this game because like even if it's
you know more of and this is where you
kind of wonder how much that casual eyes
things but a casual player who's just
gonna take a little less time they may
not get like a hundred rules on a weapon
to get that god rule they may just be
like hey I can grind after this one that
I know is good
go from there yeah I mean again sounds
great I've just I don't really see the
incentive for calm you know oh no I
still don't on that yeah that's I just
don't see you puttin one little you know
is it gonna be compressed it's just
gonna be if it's just if it's not comp
specific you definitely will have a
quiet playlist it's gonna be quiet it's
like they've got to do somebody got to
do something about that and he's so much
fixing it's like two steps forward half
a step back into the side kinda sorta
it's just they're trying I know they're
trying but yeah kompis got some
struggles so alright so now they gotta
set the record straight on a couple of
things that have come out this week one
thing from the launch trailer one thing
from the calendar got a couple other
things let's hit him I'm gonna let you
take the first one it's got your name
all over it your man there was a shot of
you you hold on you mute it out whatever
Oh
can ya Mina yep there was a shot of
trials of the nine armor in the look
trailer by mistake want to clear up any
confusion and let players know that the
trials of the night set will not be
obtainable in season of the undying
so yeah Charles man that's a good fake
out but yeah I mean they will say it's
not be obtainable in season of the
undying not ever not never just not
right now hold on WD pressed gotta drop
some major service late you were
grinding one of the things that concerns
me with both pinnacle perks and the
changes the Bungie isn't planning on
making many more new perks and that's a
world ooh little the past pinnacles the
exotics were way to test new perks hello
yeah I mean that's my thing that's what
I say it
they have been introducing some perks
with new seasons we've got things like
swashbuckler and multi kill clip and
they brought some stuff up but they need
to make like a bigger swath of perks
that just give us more options of how to
play yeah the unique perk really gave it
gave personality to the weapon it made
you want to know what does that do how
does that affect it and that that's what
I worry about because again curated is
going to feel let's be real is gonna
feel meat potatoes it's gonna feel ham
and cheese just it's not gonna be
see is this you know it's the same old
but yeah it's probably in a good
combination you know I'm saying boy yeah
we gotta see you gotta see yeah I mean
we got new mods coming I'd like to see
new perks coming too so hopefully we get
new weapon mods too
we had to revise our calendar apparently
the third time now is the third calendar
change they made I mean and this is one
of those reasons why they're always
worried about putting stuff out because
the community eats it up and saves it
and makes videos about it six seconds
later like videos are up and be like hey
here's all this stuff and it's they just
gotta forgive stuff doesn't always come
out as planned best laid plans always
change so the big changes they had are
the timing of the nightmare hunts so
raid still launches on the 5th with the
vex offensive the hero nightmare hunts
launched on the 8th that was both legend
and hero previously now you get here on
the 8th legend on the 15th so a week
later with iron banner so you've got
kind of both of those in there you've
got the exotic quest and master
nightmare hunts on the 22nd mm-hm and
then you've got the festival the dungeon
the rest of the stuff is pretty much on
pace so they spread out the nightmare
hunts dungeons the same ok
yeah a dungeon still 29 days festival
lost yeah ok yeah new graphic but yeah
so they basically spaced out hero and
legend nightmare hunts I guess as we're
leveling up which is still an odd thing
because hero was 920 legend is 950 yeah
yet you got to get to 920 for the raid
on the first 5 days and they're saying
eh give us that legend help that's it
that is they give us that legit boost
before the raid nope you're gonna have
to be working for it so little little
changes there mm-hmm
back when we were first talking about
finishers and this one I kind of saw
this coming
I'm not surprised because even I was
like hey this could be a really good
build it was probably too good the end
of to get we talked about how one of the
mods enable you to spawn heavy ammo for
your fireteam when you execute a
finisher
person running a build to pop heavy
bricks for everybody yeah that was
probably even if it was half your super
that was it sounds good that sounds a
great teammate to have that was still in
flux at the time and for balance reasons
we end up making a mod that will spawn
heavy ammo for yourself and a mod that
will spawn special ammo for your fire
team they overshot sounds like and this
is where they're still afraid of keeping
things in balance they want the content
they wanted to have a difficulty to it
and they don't whether it's the guns are
weaker and there's more of a mechanics
where the things are a little less
spongy or more spongy I don't know but
yeah there's still at that point where
if you you know if you got one or two
people that can run that heavy finisher
and you're like oh you go pop a brick
over there like I'm five on the ground I
got bricks over there guaranteed and you
still get chances at them people just
gonna be running heavy the whole time
let me ask you this question I just
thought of something do you think with
all of the nerfs right there the nurse
people lot of commuters upset with
Ashley you know far as a legendary stuff
and more so especially in the Brooks the
the kill clips the rampages right do you
think this is more so because armor 2.0
may get you really powerful so they want
to kind of get that in line do you think
do you think armor 2.0 is affecting
these decisions to nerf uh what you call
it up eat a lot of these PvE perks or
you just feel like you know maybe just
letting there's a lot of in I don't
think armor - I think armor 2.0 gives
you choice and interchangeability and
mods I don't think anything at least the
base level perks like scavengers and
reserves and stuff like that but you
forget about the big one like light
reactor the ones with I mean I'm running
build right we're certain helmets
shotgun kills
palm super energy fusion life and kills
super energy sniper kill I got billed
for that where they're giving you super
energy to get you know it's a powerful
it adds a pro like in crucible
especially or just planning gameplay I'm
running around loaded question with a
light reactor and you know I load a
question get those multi
you broke my super and I'm saying so I'm
curious if all my 2.0 maybe we're I know
we're all sad were upset I'm just trying
to be devil's advocate no sir maybe
because armor to play no in these builds
we could create can get so powerful they
felt the need to say you know we got a
pullback weapons bit otherwise they just
gonna be beasting out here like where's
your mindset with that I could see some
of that and it's not even as much as
like hey I have this set I've got my
super mods in it I want to go switch
over to rifle BAM you put the super you
know you put light reactor you put the
sniper one in there you put a you switch
them out so quick your optimal build as
your mods do unlock is it gonna be so
easily changeable okay so you're gonna
be able to like hey this is my armor set
I'm switching weapons it's like not
everybody's horde to like me you know it
has stuff so if you want to change stuff
up
you're not running with that type of
thing so I could see you being more
optimal more of the time especially it'd
be like hey I wanna run a fusion rifle
Bam Bam to person okay go like you can
change that in orbit on the fly based on
what you got yeah so I mean that's
that's why I honestly wonder like the
value of armor 2.0 for that raid race
like how how many mobs are people get
unlock in four days how much artifact
stuff is gonna unlock how much is it
gonna be worth do you have your old
perfect build or do you switch over to
this new stuff and like I'm kind of
wondering if it's gonna be better to
have that interchangeability could be
really good going the full yeah be like
hey we need everybody whispers not doing
great we got a switch over to linear
fusion rifles are crushing it right now
for some reason probably not gonna be
the thing I'll be honest I was even on
stream and I was like hey guys I've got
like a linear fusion scavenger and
really linear fusion loader they're like
delete it I was like it's a perfect
linear load delete it I was like okay
bye but I mean for whatever reason is
you'll be will be able to switch them
out quick like raid people especially
when they're trying different loadouts
and be like hey this is working auto
rifles are feeling a little better maybe
you need this stuff like I don't know I
got
I could see that definitely being a
thing but I also do think Legendary's
most of them out class primary exotics
for sure so I think it's a combination
of both
I can see definitely a little bit of
armor 2.0 making you more optimal easily
for people who aren't hoarders be like
hey I delete most of mine I've got this
set all the meta changed well crap well
meta changed ok cool done like it takes
two seconds to shift as opposed to
trying to grind out a new set or
something so no I can see that being
part of it but I also agree where you're
talking about like I mean you can move
there was somebody in chat who saying I
just run full legendaries like that
shouldn't be a thing you should always
want to have at least one exotic on you
no matter when one slot there should be
something outweighs your legendary
somewhere but yeah I mean a whole one
person popping heavy ammo for everybody
yeah that's gonna rough but then that
also is like so and that was gonna cost
like seven energy to pop heavy ammo now
if it's just for you is the cost going
to be the same is it worth seven now or
is that gonna get adjusted it's that
gonna need balanced so love to see ya I
got a feeling that void grenade damage
is still gonna be a really good build
just my opinion yeah that void damage
debuff you buff yourself just light it
up mm-hm
so yeah take a look at the calendar the
nightmare hunts will slowly trickle out
in difficulty we'll get those as we go
which really means we'll get through
three weeks before we get to really see
the high level of Nightmare hunts it's
probably not bad cuz masters are like
980 that's that's artifact alone and
pinnacle grinding I mean that's that's
gonna be some work so if that was gonna
launch that soon I think that spaces it
a little better for people so that'll be
good yeah
we're with pride shout out to Bungie
they're always awesome supporters up
there and honestly a really cool emblem
and if you ever had the pride pin before
if you haven't actually seen it on the
soar it's a really cool looking pin it
looks similar to the emblem on the page
but shout out to Nigel Nigel he's one of
the developers up there read through
this thing guys and check out his story
he's gone through the comfort that he's
had at Bungie the like support he's had
behind the company work set to do some
of the things that he does I don't to
read the whole thing it's just like it's
his thing
have you guys read as well because I'm
not gonna do this justice but really
it's one of those that like take a
minute read somebody's awesome story of
the journey they've been through in life
not just the game development just yes
reads my journey in life lesson so take
a minute read this one
send a shout-out to Nigel on Twitter if
you can find him - I don't know if he's
on there I've got a look I've followed
somebody I don't you people you know I
just want a comment real quick like
brave story you know the means just for
him to put herself out there and then
you know it just shows you the power of
video games can you know give someone
confidence in something that they may
have lacked or whatever your personal
issue is you know we're all accepting
you know I'm saying I love that Bungie
is and that is really cool and um yeah
this was it was a cool story and just to
his story about dragons age are very
very cool stuff very cool that Bungie
actually put this whole you know piece
in the table you know to salute that for
metal salute Nigel great story good
people and we support everyone in our
community
absolutely yeah I mean you got a
gardening con it doesn't matter doesn't
matter anything you're a person who
likes bungee and you're person who
enjoys destiny and we're just fans of
this game and I think that's just the
resounding like inclusivity of the
community is amazing yeah I always tell
everybody I say there's like a little
podcast pop I don't care who you are
which background sexuality politics if
you get good at this you're my friend
he's all the controllers for the audio
that's nice by the way he's holding the
controller if you like okay what's going
man I like to just come game we all all
use just in games our escape as fun it's
just it's a bonding spirit so why not
include you know that's how I feel yeah
so yeah read that story chat at the
Nigel awesome story sir
hats off for you for putting it out
there and hats off for Bungie for what
is probably gonna be one of the most
read swabs that everybody was waiting on
this is a one of the bigger chunks of it
that's awesome
always supporting amazing causes I mean
the stuff they do for st. Jude's the
pride ornament up there they're all in
all yeah you see like half the studios
out there in the parade every year in
Seattle - it's like it is so cool
everyone
but they do so absolutely no I mean
shout-out to CJ working at the the dream
company up there so yeah a bit down
therefore is mister fireteam chat is
ready making those awesome videos moving
on to the next one we got Bungie rewards
you gonna want this thing sir
I won't surprise you no you don't look
inside it's fire I want to be inside the
beat house you just wear the jacket
inside out if you really want that thing
on your back it's just like when it's
closed up is so basic like oh my do you
like I want to show off that okay then
you have a different I am probably
weren't the worst person to talk about
fashion ever
first off so that glitty know I was like
but it was like for like I don't know if
I could wear a jacket that's that like
if it was the inside-out I don't know if
I could wear a jacket that's that flashy
man alright that would be extremely
flashy right no doubt all I'm saying I
just wish the outside of the jacket did
some I feel like it's just lacking
something it just feels so Plain Jane do
you want like my Harley Davidson version
of a back logo and it's like the little
give me a back logo like you don't my
problem I'm gonna put gemstones on the
back of your go nice be out we're
warlocks we gotta be we gotta be flat
here's the deal who's gonna see this
emblem you're the only person that knows
about this like only you go to bed at
night with your jacket in look at the
inside see fly it looks no one in the
street can see that no one like that
that's my issue it it's like give me
something man like that is your thing
am i buggin or it's like the alright you
see how that you did jacket on the
sleeves hums when a bicep part yeah
where it has little are those really
they almost look like pasted or like
nobody look they just literally slapped
those on the outside but I've seen it
before they're gonna be like little like
patches basically but they're they're
gonna be patches on either side they're
just showing you what the graphic of the
patch looks like cuz it's the way it's
laying right now you can't see it it
would
fold in half so it's the full patch is
what it would look like listen this this
thing had to pretend to be something and
again is it the worst thing I've ever
seen no but it's like how do you hide
the coolest part of the job all right so
after the jacket there could be weird
editing in here who knows but sorry if
the sound is a little weird had an odd
cutoff but we've got one other reward
which I'm actually really excited about
this one so what else do we have a
chance to earn with regards to bunch of
awards well we have the any player who
beats the garden salvation raid claims
their cult or we said the jacket but
then many of you don't know who don't
enjoy rushing to content so even if you
aren't ready to take on the raid on the
15th of October any player who completes
garden of salvation during season of the
undying will be eligible to purchase a
special rate t-shirt through Bungie
rewards and we've got the big question
what e what the hell is going on man so
the shirt has some spoilers on it they
say so the show's share when the shirt
looks like after the raid is completed
holiday right now Osiris he's back its
Osiris its face I don't think so I'm
gonna go ahead and say let's save us
from the vex offensive for one I like
this because not everybody give us a
chance to go after the jacket if you
can't go after the jacket you still get
something for the raid and the rate is
the big content if you actually if you
only beat the raid once you just want to
check the box you're like mmm you can
get something for it and honestly like
their designs always cool and if it's
spoiler related I don't be like boss or
like jumping puzzle theme or something
but I don't really care what the spoiler
is I just I hope I can't wait to see
what it looks like he's got it listen I
just want the emblem behind the shirt I
will take that everybody shows
I love the blue stuff I it looks cool I
think oh yes these it'll be Osiris or
in mercury best joke ever shout out to
the the cul-de-sac the roundabout shout
out to there's neither the sparrow but
uh no I think III think it almost feels
like even though I'm joking it's clearly
something or some entity that they don't
want us to that's gonna that's gonna hit
big time or what's going on with this so
again I don't know what it's gonna be
but um it's funny that they doing this
but I do like Rea shirts that's cool
like yeah I need more of that now like
one of my favorite shirts don't rack up
the UM phone with the aurochs and the
crota yeah I was yeah rate of pinnacle
activities man like they need to do that
so I'm wid all that so yeah they said
well that's not all players can also
earn a free Eris morn papercraft Best
Buy completely the main shadow cube
quest mm main show cube quest don't like
the campaign so the end of season 8 if
you're already receiving Bungie
newsletters you can visit their wards
and get all of that stuff so they are
full steam ahead I'm not gonna bore you
guys with technical details that were
launched if you are playing on PC read
the tuam please read this week at Bungie
go to a bunch of net go for the one on
the 27th or 26th and make sure you read
this about pre loading on Steam you can
download already but it's also about the
PC migration how to start that process
how to kick off like the order of like
link your steam account to Bungie if
desired makes your naval Cross save turn
on steam log on on the proper account
that you want to make sure is on Steam
like there are certain orders to this
read this in detail they put it out big
bold letters on certain parts its
technical pieces so if you're not on PC
I know how few guys may not care but if
you're on PC please make sure and go
through the steps correctly please
please please please please PLEASE yeah
don't get caught out there follow these
steps very variable
they did say the delay into the
forsaking license like just having the
database to run through kicking
everybody over they said during the 24
hours they hope most of that will be
done so if the delay there they're
hoping it's pretty minimal so you're not
actually going to be locked out for
second stuff for hopefully as long and
also that does mean shadow throne is
actually now on the table come October
1st because it was
gonna be cursed week three yeah and that
is gonna be something to do now but I
don't know if it's gonna give you
powerful here but we'll be able to see
from the director so all good things
yeah
only thing I'm worried about all this is
I don't know that's I didn't hear
anything like I said I said the only
thing I'm concerned about a that's gonna
hurt me is I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to survive at 24 maybe by love for
destiny it's hard oh my god yes you will
tease just go go look at the sunshine
everything don't mean how many games on
switch listen man you got one love when
it goes way you miss it you will survive
for one day if not then you shouldn't
play if you can't survive for a day you
shouldn't play the game right there let
me get my fix man yeah you'll survive
without it and then you're gonna get
more than you know what to do with it's
good everybody gets a palate cleanser
one day of sunlight watching a movie guy
that shot a TV show let the hands rest
up a little bit you're gonna play so
much during that next week are you off
that week I do you have though are you
now are you gonna eat are you getting
sick because I want to at least take one
day but my here's my biggest friend I'll
make this quick
is we know how MMO launches go and this
has been fairly good know what I'm
concerned is I take the day of launch
right I take off the day I become
impaired at work and I you know I'm not
able to come in I wait and let's say
they have an issue like oh my god
everyone the whole the server just cuz
remember we get light players right oh
yeah we're getting a whole influx of of
people so I'm worried about maybe taking
the day after and then say okay bye then
problems will be mitigated it should be
more smoother and I'll still I mean I'll
still get some launched game gaming in
I'll just go to work that night but then
the next stage it's kind of like bull
ease out so I'm debating how I'm gonna
do it but I think I'm not too late but
like a longer late week yeah I might not
yeah we're hey dad that's what I'm
looking at
Wednesday night probably not and just
just rock out these get it I just want
like one full Bay of going in one cycle
of being awake playing until your eyes
hurt and exactly no I just wanted one
strong just like a lot of Visine in
there dripping in the eyes you know keep
those eyes fresh but yeah if you plan on
playing on PC and anyway from battlenet
with crossfade just read about this make
sure the integration and the activation
of everything follow the steps do it
right just make sure you do it's all I
gotta say there's a lot of steps and I
don't want to say anything to get it
wrong that's literally why I'm not
saying it they have the text up they
went through all the details just read
it please say it says you got old
characters follow the instructions to a
tee yep all that stuff between steam
licenses and battlenet and silver and
everything like that it's gonna be a
thing mmm a couple movies of the week
and that pretty much wraps everything
one thing we missed oh that premonition
pulse rifle thing oh yeah that was
actually kind of a good detail so yeah
so follow you can say it you got it
yeah following the launch of shadow keep
next players will be able to items added
to destiny to using the in-game
collections before then we'd like to
make players aware of a known issue with
one particular weapon listing following
the launcher shadow keep the collection
listing for the premonition legendary
pulse rifle will state that it is found
by exploring the book this weapon
specific source is actually the new
dungeon and that's cool which will
become available sometime after shadow
keeps launch players will also occur
other issues or launching light shadow
keep simply so what do you think man
getting a new a new pulse no pulse for
what we're getting worn but we're
getting weapons from I mean there's this
one and there's a shotgun that looks
like a two there might be multiple
weapons the dungeon may have some stuff
like the dungeon is gonna be dungeons
gonna be a thing for everybody it's
gonna be around it's just gonna open up
it's got a launch date it's not gonna be
on three week cycle I think
the dungeons gonna be a big thing I'm
really looking forward to it yeah and
just the fact that you got like dungeons
specific item hell yeah
absolutely this is a five team raid man
it's really yeah three-person raid light
red light mechanics long like multiple
encounters like knots trying to get
soloing to do it's gonna kick my button
many times trust me fighting crazy big
lover that's it I'm gonna fight that
love at night all by myself and get
smashed in the face so many times it's
gonna happen you will not be fast enough
to get away from lava night oh you gotta
get you gone man we got you guys yeah we
got about an hour so mmm all right guys
well thank you very much
tell them what you got going anything
for iron Lords podcast this week yeah
man it should be of course at Lord
kognito well first of all figure out all
this shout out to the chat today cuz did
you guys have an awesome
yo not only did they rock out with us
you know I'm saying like putting up yes
my crappy connection yeah stuff we going
through and got still there and keep
coming back like shoutout to y'all I
know ease frustrate just to see everyone
still rock with us while he's going
through it is just it's tremendous so we
definitely appreciate you guys sticking
by the campfire yo you already know
where I'm at at Lord coccolino on
Twitter you know iron law podcast on
YouTube and Lords of gaming dotnet
tremendous articles we got up right now
please alright every give you I got shot
my boy out real quick my boy Josh
reading we've had him on the show um
please check out his shadow keep primer
series I'm telling y'all right now if
you like lore if you love love put one
of his articles in there I'm telling you
right now he every week every Tuesday he
has been giving a background of every
race in destiny what's going on the
current state leading in the shadow keep
what to expect from them it is
tremendous writing please check this out
man this thing got me high I was reading
about the VEX the I was learning stuff
he told me stuff I don't even know you
know saying this is this is by smiling
game level stuff Josh reading Lord gave
me that net articles in description
please check it out and from me this
Sunday iron wall podcast
11:00 a.m. NFL friendly
time so please check that out we will
have Dan butch Cole the CEO of play
crafting he's very big in the community
pax West PAX East we're talking with the
top gaming conventions latest that's
going on with a state of playing
PlayStation inside Xbox just gaming
stuff and doing some gaming history like
we do so please hang out with the Lords
and again of course every Friday the
last work that campfire the passion the
debates be showing EE that he's wrong
he's sometimes showing that me him me
that he's right but you know sometimes
take some L some time you know there but
of knowledge really really appreciate
you guys Mitch from Amanda's tremendous
we see the support we see the tweets
please again last thing club will be um
the last at last pod so please check
that out on Twitter that is the last
word Twitter account social follow
social support check out he puts up the
audio I'll try to get that up as soon as
is up and of course the boarding stuff
he'll all put up on our respective
channels so that's what I got II
stressful day but we got the rip brother
indeed hopefully that is the goal but
yeah for me you guys know what I got
going on again the giveaway for the
stream deck if you don't even really
know too much about honest there so I'm
just go look up us like stream deck
review just go watch one of them people
do there's one on Linus tech tips
there's multiple ones out that everybody
loves the thing so even if you may not
be a content creator you may think about
it who knows it's a really cool thing so
go check out that giveaway on my Twitter
the link will be in there for all the
ways to get into that one twitch you
guys know you're watching here so if
you're not watching yet follow me on
Twitch I'll be streaming as long as my
internet gets its act together and then
of course still more content I got
videos to try and get out to you guys
today
couple up over the weekend probably
something on Monday for and I'll get
hopefully a new light player series out
for a couple things as well just kind of
keep new light videos going as much as I
can so that's my goal of the weekend is
probably if I'm on Twitch this weekend
when I'm recovering it's probably gonna
be making content for new light players
mostly so trying to give them an idea
what is coming because
I gotta try to decipher everything we
just did and put that make have that
makes sense for new layer new player
self a little more sleeps before the
shadow it's gonna be good man don't be
payable alright well you guys have been
awesome thank you for putting up with
everything today thank you very much
we're gonna go send a raid over to a guy
who's working on some comp and PvP love
right now so if you got any interest in
that we're gonna send you guys over say
hated him but thank you guys very much
on the stream today you guys have been
awesome you guys can catch this on audio
you guys know it's on the podcast
platforms everywhere and for episode 75
three-quarters of the way to a hundred
episode 75 on September 27th that next
week is shadow keep and we cannot wait
you get to sleep you get to sleep Friday
Saturday Sunday and Monday for sleeps
guys and then it's here so have an
awesome one we'll see you soon and it
has been the last word this word